طيب انا مش قدامي ممكن الله يخليك
هو نفسه
مساء الخيرات احنا على الهواء احمد مساء
الخيرات على حضراتكم اتمنى لكم امسيه
سعيده معنا ان شاء الله
بدات الاسئله سريعه كنت عاوز اتكلم بس
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته
مرحبا بك سيد الله يخليك رمزي ممكن حلقه
عن قناه السويس و اسباب توقف مشروع
المنطقه الصناعيه في حدود معلومات عن ان
مشروع محور قناه السويس والمناطق الصناعيه
المختلفه لم تتوقف بعضها يسير بواتير
معقوله جدا زي المنطقه الصناعيه الصينيه
بعضها واخذ همم يعني متباطئ بعضها همم لم
يبدا بعد لكن متوقف لا وهناك زي اي مشروع
كبير طبعا فيه صعوبات ليست قليله يعني
خصوصا انه مع الصعوبات اللي هي موجوده
داخل مصر
جاءت الازمات العالميه المختلفه الكرونه
والحرب الرسائل الاوكرانيه لكن في حدود
معلوماتي ما فيش حاجه متوقفه بمعنى انه تم
صرف النظر عنها السلام عليكم حبيبنا يا
استاذ سيد ما هي الاثار السلبيه للتعويم
على الفرد المصري الحبيب
وكيفيه تفاديها او تخفيفها هل يوجد بوادر
صناعات هذا العام غير روسيا واوكرانيا
بالنسبه للجزء الاول اي خفض له اي عمله
اذا كانت مصريه سودانيه مغربيه وتقدر يعني
لازم يكون لها اثر قاسي جدا على المواطن
لانه هو عباره عن تخفيض للقيمه او القدره
الشرعيه للعمله فاللي انت كنت بتشتريه
مثلا عند جنيه او دينار بقت تشتريه عند
اثنين او اكثر يعني على حسب خفض قيمه
العمله مستحيل انه الاجور والدخول تتضاعف
لو تضاعفت يبقى احنا ما عملناش حاجه يعني
وبالتالي الاثر كبير جدا على اي دوله
بتخفض العمله ولكن دائما طبعا الكلام ده
اتشرح يعني لو انتم عايزين نقعدوا انا تحت
امركم احنا قلنا في قناتنا نعرف الام اللي
بتكلم من خلالها وقلناه على نعرف اقتصاد
مع زميلي وصديقي الاقتصادي المتميز هنيجي
هنا انما همم كالعاده يعني انت الدوله
اللي بتلجا لخفض قيمه عملتها بتلجا لسبب
من الاثنين اذا كان متعمد يعني اما ان هي
دوله صناعيه عندها جهاز انتاج ضخم جدا وهي
عاوزه تستفيد من خفض قيمه عملتها عشان
تصدر اكثر بعض الدول عملت كده الصين دائما
كانت ملتهبه من جانب الولايات المتحده ان
هي بتخفض قيمه عملتها لهذا السبب وده احنا
ما لناش دعوه ده لكن في دول كثيره اللي
احنا بننتمي اليها كل مصر من الدول ديت
السؤال حضرتك يعني
اللي هي الدول اللي عندها اوضاع اقتصاديه
صعبه وعندها شح في العملات الاجنبيه
وبالتالي عندها مشاكل مختلفه يعني في
ميزان المدفوعات والحساب الجاري وبتضطر ان
هي تخفضتها
الجزء الثاني من السؤال اه طبعا ما هو ده
كان موضوع حلقه النهارده اللي انا كنت
ناوي اكلمكم فيه
واذا حبيتهم ممكن نخصص له حلقه على اساس
الحلقه بتكون مرتبه اكثر من الهواء اللي
بننتقل فيه من سؤال الثاني وهي انه في
مطلع في نهايه كل عام وفي مطلع العام
التالي
مراكز ابحاث في كل دول العالم بتتكلم اذا
كانت رسميه او تانس اللي هي مراكز الابحاث
بتتكلم على اهم بؤر الصراع في العالم
في كل دول العالم بيحصل دائما بتختلف
القوائم على حسب الدوله والمركز اللي
بيعملها لانه ما يمثل خطرا على الصين مش
هو بالضبط اللي بيمثل خطر على المكسيك او
على دول المغرب العربي او على اوروبا
وبالتالي بتختلف انما هناك شبه اتفاق ان
في مجموعه من بؤر التوتر اللي موجوده في
عام 2023 على راس كل بؤر الصراع والمشتركه
في كل قوائم بؤر الصرع والتوتر في العالم
كله طبعا اوكرانيا اللي هي ام الازمات
لانه ايا كنت مكانك في على خريطه هذا
العالم فانت متاثر بالحرب في اوكرانيا
لكن فيه ايه فيه بؤر اخرى مثلا
ايران على الارجح في 2023 هتبقى بؤره
ساخنه لاسباب ممكن نتكلم عليها اذا حبيته
باكستان ربما تبقى بؤره اخرى لانه في
اضطرابات وفي حلقه بعنوان باكستان لو
بحثتم عنها هي مرشحه الاضطرابات سياسيه
واضطرابات سياسيه مع ازمات اقتصاديه وصفه
سيئه جدا ل همم او اخبار سيئه جدا دوله
عندنا طبعا اليمن عندنا اثيوبيا عندنا كل
الدول منطقه الساحل ولما باقول منطقه
الساحل في افريقيا يعني تجاوز كده دول
المغرب العربي ليبيا وانزل تحت هتلاقي
بوركينا فاسو النيجر تشاد دول تحديدا يعني
الدول اللي هي فيها ازمات اكتر من غيرها
عندك الدول منطقه البحيرات الكبرى او
العظمى اللي هي تحديدا يعني الكونغو على
وجه التحديد فيها مشاكل فيها انفلات امني
عندنا الحقيقه مجموعه عند طبعا تايوان
تايوان تقدر تحطها تصعد بها تبقى كده عندك
اوكرانيا عندك
تايوان وعندك ايران دول الابرز عندك
مجموعه ثانيه من الازمات ربما تكون عندك
همم
اللي هو الصراع ما بين ارمينيا واثر على
جان
دول يعني الاكثر ورودا في معظم القوائم
ممكن نضيف لهم كمان مجموعه من الصراعات
المنخفضه الكثافه يعني اللي كانت ملتهبه
يعني بقت صراعات مزمله هي الصراعات موجوده
ما بتمثلش ضغط جامد على العالم لانها
صراعات منخفضه الكثافه زي سوريا زي
الصومال وزي ليبيا هل الصراعات منخفضه
الكثافه يعني ايه منخفضه الكثافه يعني
مثلا لما بدا صراع في اليمن
2015/2016 ده كان بالغده وواخذ اهتمام
العالم كله
بت- تايم اصبح الصراع موجود لكن منخفض
الكثافه يعني الاشتعال مش بنفس الحته
الخسائر مش بنفس الحته هل الصراعات منخفضه
الحده اقل خطوره مش دائما احيانا بيكون ما
فيش خسائر بمعنى ان ما فيش قتلى وما فيش
جرحه ولكن بيعقد علاقات الدول اللي هي
متورطه في هذا الصراع ولو عاوزين مثال
صارخ جدا شوفه قضيه الصحراء وازاي قضيه
الصحراء والخلاف عليها ما بين الصحراويين
والله المغرب ما بين الصحه الصحراويه
المدعوين من الجزائر والمغرب هذا الصراع
بيشكل يعني جزء كثير جدا من السياسات
سياسات او الجزء الاكبر من سياسات
والعلاقه الجزائر والمغرب وعلاقتهم بالدول
الاخرى في افريقيا واوروبا والعالم
وبيعطل التعاون الاقتصادي في كل المغرب
العربي او شمال افريقيا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله احمد ابو سمره
همم
احمد اظن كان ارسل لي رساله وقلت له بس
انا اسف احمد معلش انا عارف سامحني انت
كان في
صديقين بعده كان حضرتك واحد منهم كان
سؤالك معلش بس ابعث لي مجرد رقص العنوان
وانا هافتكره يعني هل هو السؤال اللي كان
يتعلق به
ايران ولا سؤال اخر معلش استاذنك فكرني
مجرد جمله وانا هفتكر على طول
لانه في نفس الوقت اللي انت بعثت لي فيه
وعدتك ان انا هاجاوبه همم كان في طلب
مشابه فياريت بس ابعث لي راس الموضوع تحيه
لسيد ربنا يخليك انا اياد من سوريا سؤالي
هل الحرب العالميه الثالثه بدات بحرب
روسيا اوكرانيا وما هي السيناريوهات انهاء
الصراع الاقرب للواقع ومن اين تتوقع بدء
الحرب في تايوان هذا سؤال مركب بها اياد
انا يعني قلت لحضرتك قبل كده وقلت
لحضراتكم انه
الحرب الكلام على الحرب العالميه الثالثه
ده دايما يعني كان مطروح من قبل ما يعني
بمجرد ما انتهت الحرب العالميه الثانيه
تقريبا واول مره تجدد الحديث عن حرب
عالميه ثالثه في حرب الكوريتين ده يعني
بعد فتره صغيره جدا في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه من انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
انما همم وطبعا كان تجدد ثاني بشكل جد في
62 ازمه الصواريخ ثم هدا بشكل كبير ما
كانش الكلام مطروح على الاقل يعني من
الاخر الثمانينات وحتى اندلاع الحرب
الروسيه الاخرانيه كل شيء وارد والله هو
صحيح دائما اللي بيستبعد فكره حرب عالميه
ثالثه بيقول حرب عالميه ايه حرب عالميه
معناها انه تشتبك روسيا وتشترك
حلف شمال الاطلسي هو الولايات المتحده مع
بعض دي قوه نوويه يعني نهايه العالم
وبيستبعده بيقول لك ان الاطراف المشتبكه
في الحرب دائما اطراف رشيد ده والخوف
هيمنع كل الناس من تطوير الصراع يوجد نظر
انما وجهه النظر الثانيه انه
مهما كنت حريص فالاخطاء دائما وارده ومن
بين الاخطاء ديت انه الصراع اللي هم
اعتقدوا لما دخلت روسيا كانت تعتقد انه
صراع سوف ينتهي سريعا هتحسموا لصالحها
والغرب لما اعتقد انه هيصعد الدعم ليه
اوكرانيا كان بيعتقد ان دوت قد يرضع بوتن
لكن الواضح ان احنا دلوقت بقى لنا سنه سوف
نكمل عاما خلال يعني ايام قليله انه
الصراع بيزداد حتى حده والخطوط الحمراء
بيتم تجاوزها شيئا فشيئا وبالتالي للاسف
كل شيء وارد يعني
[موسيقى]
من اين تتوقع بدء الحرب تايوان الحرب في
تايوان ما لهاش غير الطريق واحد بس او
يعني يعتبر ايه خطوتين ان تايوان تفكر في
اعلان استقلالها ما هي طيران حتى الان لا
ترغب في الانضمام الى الصين في خطوتين
والصين تصر على ان تايوان جزء منها متى
تبدا الحرب في حالتين انه تايوان تعلن
استقلالها رسميا وهي خطوه لم تقبل عليها
ابدا منذ 49 لكن لا سببين مختلفين في
البدايه كانت بتقول انا الصين اصلا يعني
الصينيين ما كان في حرب اهليه انتهت في
سنه 49 بانتصار الشيعيين على القوميين
القوميين فرو الى تايوان واقاموا حكومه
هناك قالوا ان هي بتمثل كامل الصين
معنى ذلك ان هم لم يكن ما اعترفوش
بالحكومه الشيوعيه اللي كانت موجوده في
بكين والحكومه بكين بتقول انا امثل كل
الصين بما فيهم الجزيره همم تايوان لكن
بعد كده بعد ما تم الاستسلام الى ان الصين
الام هي الصين الام وانا مجرد جزيره لكن
باتم في بقى
الطيارات الانفصاليه في تايوان ما بتقولش
انا بامثل الصين بس بتقول انا لا ارغب في
العوده الى الصين
الصين مصر على استعاده الطيران وبالتالي
الحرب ما قدمهاش غير مش ممكن تتم الا
بطريقه
الاولانيه انه حيوان تعلن استقلالها رسميا
وهي خطوه لم تقبل عليها وهذا امر مستبعد
على الاقل في الابد المنظور لانها خطوه
انتحاريه بنجرب حكومه ومن جانب الراغبين
في الانفصال عن الصين خصوصا انه امرهم
ماشيه يعني
الامر الثاني انه الصين تقرر ان اللحظه
مناسبه لضم تايوان بالقوه
انا انا جبت كيف
كيف حالك اخي انا اسف مش عارف الكلمه اللي
في الوسط لكن اهلا وسهلا
كان صديقنا كان ناشط جدا في
المباشر اللي فات وسال اسئله كثيره صديقك
صح صديقك
ممكن تتكلم عن النسويه والسؤال ده جاء لنا
المره اللي فاتت انا قاعده يعني تطرح انت
عارف يا صديقي العزيز اااه مين عبد الله
حقيقي كمل موضوعات
المؤجله مش منها النساويه انت طرحت
الاسبوع اللي فات وانا اظنك تقصد ان هي
لحركه الدفاع عن النساء اللي اذا كان تقصد
وحقوق المراه اللي اذا كان لك تعريف اخر
يعني
انا وعدتك انه ممكن نستضيف حد ونطرح
المساله بس لو انت قصدك حاجه محدده خلاف
يعني تطور الدعوه لحقوق المراه والفم يا
ريت تقول لي
عود عوده حميدا الفارس ربنا يخليك والله
يا اخي سيد اتمنى منك ان تلتزم الحياد ولا
تتبنى الروايه المغربيه المضله وارجع الى
مقالات
نحنا عاملين
[موسيقى]
فيها صديقنا ده من الجزائر بيقول كلام بسم
الله ما شاء الله عدد الاسئله معلش انا
اسف انا هرجع للسؤال والله انا عشان ما
تتخيلش ان انا تجاهلته انا هرجع لسؤال
حضرتك الاسئله جريت مني السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله راضيه الله يخليك السلام عليكم
استاذ سيد تحياتي لحضرتك من انجلترا ممكن
تشرح المشتقات الماليه وهل ساعدت في
الازمه الاقتصاديه المشتقات الماليه هتبقى
موضوع حلقه قريبه جدا على اقتصاد نعرف
المشتقات الماليه
الدليفريتس اللي بعض الاقتصاديين سموها
القنبله النوويه الماليه هتكون موضوع حلقه
قريبا جدا خلال هذا الشهر ان شاء الله
اقتصاد نعرف
او نعرف
السلام عليكم
استاذ سيد تحياتي لك من العراق الله يخليك
ما رايك ده اخونا محمد مالك بالصناعات
العسكريه التركيه لماذا ظهرت في عرض
اردوغان والله لانه واضح هو مهتم الراجل
هو كان عنده ما هو الرجل له مزايا وله
عليه زي اي سياسي كبير الراجل طور صناعات
كثيره متعدده منها الصناعات العسكريه وما
تنساش ان دوله في حلف شمال الاطلسي وكان
قبل الخلافات الاخيره اللي وطرت علاقاته
بالغرب كان الجميع بيتسابق على دعم
ويؤيده دول الحلفه اطلس الولايات المتحده
الاوروبيين التوتر ده حصل بس يعني في
السنوات الاخيره وتحديدا من بعد الاحداث
في سوريا ويمكن مش من اولها كمان من 2014
ل2015 وبالتالي مزيد من التخطيط الجيد
اللي همم تم التمهيد اليه في سنوات حكم
الاولى بالاضافه الى كده كان في كبير دعم
من الغرب والشرق وكل مكان تركيا كانت في
الفتره لجميع بيكتب عنها التجربه التركيه
انه كان زيرو مشاكل وكله اصدقاء فكان
الجميع بيتسابق لدعموا
كيف ترى مستقبل تونس السياسي والاقتصادي
وهل ستواجه مصير لبنان الاجابه المختصره
جدا يمكن ان تواجه مصير لبنان مالمع يعني
هي ظروفها احسن شويه من لبنان لان لبنان
لبنان يعني ههه دائما عنده فراغ سياسي حتى
لما بيكون في حكومه دائما في اكثر من راس
دايما الايدي الخارجيه كثيره جدا يعني
ظروف لبنان حاله استثنائيه انما ممكن جدا
انه يواجه متاعب شديده خصوصا انه تونس
المخب كلها سواء يعني اللي في السلطه او
في المعارضه مشغولين
بترتيب البيت السياسي
وشغالين في بقدره بسيط من التوفيق يعني
ولكن ده مفهوم انما القضايا الاقتصاديه هم
غافلين عنها من ناحيه وحتى لو مش مغفلين
بسبب اهتمامهم الشريدي جدا بتصفيه
الحسابات وانه كل واحد يحسن الصراع ليه
لصالحه طبعا الاقتصاد تم اهله بشكل كبير
واقتصاد تونس بلد صغير يعني ما يتحملش
لانه بيقعد سنه واثنين وثلاثه وعشره همم
في هذا الفراغ السياسي والسرعه السياسي
هديه لانصار الاطلسي
سامحني مش فاهم الرساله ارجو الجواب من
تتوقع في حرب اوكرانيا في كلمه اتوقع
في كلمه اعتقد يبقى روسيا
اذا كانت لابد في كلمه مساء الخيرات استاذ
سيد الله يخليك يا ياسر هل هناك ازمه
عالميه لمياه الشرب وما هي تداعياتها لا
مش اسم عالميه في مياه الشرب الناس في
ازمه في الفراش ووتر او الماء العذب اللي
بيستخدم في الشرب طبعا هو بيستخدم في
الزراعه الى اخره عكس الماء المالح اللي
هو مياه البحار والمحيطات ودي قصه بقى لها
سنوات واا هي ازمه فعلا وفي نقص
بيتفاقم في دول وللاسف منطقه الشرق الاوسط
واحده من اسوا
الرايتس او المعادلات اللي فيها ازمات همم
الماء العذب او الفراش وتر المغرب فيها
تونس فيها مش عارف الجزائر الحقيقه بس مش
هندهش اذا كان فيها مصر طبعا
عندك العراق عندك لبنان عندك سوريا اااه
فا مشكله كبيره الحقيقيه
وده مرتبط بالتغير المناخي والتغير
المناخي بيجي للدول الفقيره والدول الغنيه
بس الفرق لما بيكون دوله غنيه ومستقره
سياسيه بيبقى عمليه الاداب تايشن او
التاقلم مع التغيرات المناخيه الجفاف
ملوحه الارض همم نقص الامطار يعني هبوط
الامطار كل ده بيقدروا يتاقلموا عليه بشكل
اسرع بيقدر يجيبوا تكنولوجيا انت عندك ناس
عندك الاردن وعندك اسرائيل
اسرائيل على نفس البقعه بالاضافه ان هي
سرقت يعني همم
الاردن وسرقه مياه لبنان الى اخره طبعا
بها الفلسطينيين بس في سبب اضافه اللي
بيخليها اقل معاناه في المياه وهي
التكنولوجيا تحليه المياه اللي عاوزه
تقنيات متوفرتش للاردن وعاوز ايه امكانيات
برده ماليه متوفرتش للاردن
السلام عليكم
اخي الفاضل متى ممكن تنسحب منظمه التحرير
من اتفاقيه اصله
نتفق يعني تتفق يعني تقصد انها تسحب
اعترفها بالاسرائيل
وان هي تحل المنظمه وتعود الى او تحل
الحكومه يعني وتعود همم منظمه مقاومه
بالمعدل اللي انا شايفه في ظل وجود الرئيس
محمود عباس وعدد منه من الشخصيات اللي هي
حاولوا يعني لا اعتقد ان هذه الخطه يمكن
ان تتخذ ابدا لانه قناعه الرئيس محمود
عباس بنيت على ان افضل حل للتعامل مع
اسرائيل اللي هو التفاوض فاذا فشلت في
التفاوض فعليك ان تلجا الى التفاوض فاذا
فشلت ثانيه في التفاوض تستمر في التفاوض
على فكره انا مش بسخر والله بس هكذا كان
تصوره وهو راجل لا يمكن السخريه منه عنده
اختبارات عظيمه جدا وله تصور كبير بس انا
باقول هو كان لهجه وكان عنده تصور يعني
احنا لو استخدمنا العنف ده بيخدم اسرائيل
هتضربنا بشكل اكبر وربما كان وقتها كان ال
همم
يعني المناخ ما كانش يسمح بغير كده لكن
عموما هو كمان في اسباب ثانيه دعته
للاستمرار في هذا النهج وهو ادراكه مع
تمام تفكك الجبهه الداخليه الفلسطينيه مع
انصراف كثير من حلفاءه العرب وغير العرب
باستثناء عدد قليل يعني شايف ان المعركه
في غير صالحه
همم وبالتالي الخطوه اللي بتسال عليها
هتبقى يعني اخر ملاذ اخر ملاذ يمكن ان
يفكر فيه تفكر فيه السلطه الفلسطينيه بشكل
الرئيس ابو مازن او يعني المجموعه التي
تسير على نهجه
هل الافلام والمسلسلات تؤثر على الراي
العام ده هو خروف حزين انت مستنيه كده
اوكي الغرب فمثلا بعض الافلام الامريكيه
تظهر الرجل الروسي على انه الرجل الهمجي
اه طبعا تؤثر ازاي مش بتؤثر يعني الدراما
ديت هي كتاب الرجل
الغير يعني
مش عاوز اقوله غير مثقف احنا كلنا بنتفرج
على دراما بس لما بتكون هي مصدر المعلومه
الاساسيه همم فهي تقريبا كتاب من لا يقرا
انت بتستقي معلوماتك منين الشخص المثقف
بيقرا بيسافر بيسمع من مصادر جيده وبيشوف
دراما الشخص اللي هو يعني بسيط بيشوف
دراما بس تقريبا يعني وبالتالي هي بالغه
التاثير والدليل على انه مش بس الدراما
انت لما بتشوف مثلا مثلا يقول لك انه في
حرب بين ارمينيا وادريان في اقليم جورنو
كهرباء بيتهيا لك ان انت لو رحت ارمينيا
او ادرى بايجان ان انت ممكن تتعرض الى
كانت مدفع لا هو في الاقليم
انت عندك مثلا اضطرابات موجوده في
[موسيقى]
في اي دوله من الدول بتعتقد انه
في مدينه منها واضطرابات او مظاهرات
بتعتقد ان انت ما تقدرش تنزل مطرها
فبيتاثر الصوره الذهنيه
واحده من انجح التجارب لتغيير
الصوره الذهنيه عن بلد في الفتره الاخيره
كانت الدراما التركيه
الدراما التركيه نقلت الاهتمام باللغه
التركيه والحياه التركيه الى قطاعات واسعه
جدا جدا جدا من البيوت العربيه والشباب
العربي ويمكن الفتيات والسيدات اكثر ما
عنديش احصاءات بس هكذا يعني ده الانطباع
اللي بيجيء لي يعني عندهم اعتقاد ان هي
يعني كلها بيوت جميله وشوارع نظيفه جدا
والحياه لطيفه يعني ارتبطوا بالنجوم
السلام عليكم الدراما المصريه كانت كده في
فتره الخمسينات والستينات انا مش باقول
كده يعني علشان همم
يعني في سبب يعني انه كانت واحده من ادوات
الرئيس جمال عبد الناصر الناصريه انه يؤثر
وانه ينشر النفوذ المصري في افريقيا
والدول العالم الثالث كانت الدراما
المصريه
والسينما المصريه همم استخدمت
نعم القواصر والنفود المصري بشكل كبير ودي
قصه يطول شرحها يعني
وارجعوا الافلام محمد رضا في الادغال
والحاجات ديت اللي كانت بتشرف عليها اجهزه
المخابرات المصريه
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد تحياتي لحضرتك من
انجلترا ممكن قلنا حاضر المشتقات الماليه
مساء الخير ممكن حلقه عن عديم الجنسيه في
الكويت بدون
بعتذر ما عنديش معلومات كفايه يعني ده فهد
ازاي اا مرحبا بك يا استاذ سيد انا باذكر
برمجه لكن للاسف تم ايقاف المنحه بسبب
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه السؤال امتى هيتحسن
الاقتصاد المصري
والله يا احمد الاقتصاد المصري يعني اذا
كان انت بتتكلم على الشهر او الشهرين او
العام اللي جاي ويتحسن دي كلمه نسبيه لا
اظن انه تبقى في متاعب خلال 23
[موسيقى]
وطبعا التحسن بيكون بطيء يعني لانه في
الاخر في مشاكل في مصر نتيجه تتعلق بعوامل
خاصه بمصر وبتزداد سوءا بسبب الاوضاع
الخارجيه
في حال اجتمع عدد كبير من الدول للتخلي عن
الدولار كالصين وروسيا ما هي السنه
الهجريه
الدولار وماذا سوف يحدث في امريكا في حال
حدود ذلك وما هي العمله التي ستتهايمن
برايك وما هو زمن حدود ذلك
اخونا اياد الاجابه
البسيطه جدا انه على مدى السنين وعشره و15
سنه انا طبعا ما اقدرش ان انا يعني يكون
ادي ارقامي يعني ولكن لسنوات المقبله سوف
يظل الدولار هو العمله المسيطره في العالم
ما تنساش ان الدولار الاقتصاد الامريكي
بيتعرض لمشاكل والدول الثانيه اللي عندها
يعني
عمل عملات بتحاول ان هي تنافس بها او
بتصعد زي اليورو زي الوان الى اخره هي
كمان عندها مشاكل كبيره
فده مؤكد انه للسنوات سوف يظل التوراه
الدولار الدولار هو عمله مهيمنه انما
المؤكد ايضا انه مع الوقت هو حصته وحصه
التجاره الامريكيه حتى الان يعني على مدار
سنه بتتراجع وبالتالي حصه الدولار في
الاحتياطات وفي التجاره العالميه بتتراجع
نسبيا امام عملات بتاخذ يعني نسبه من
الدولار بالنسبه مش ضخمه انما يعني
اخي سيد بعثت تعليقات كثيره بخصوص الكتاب
الجديد
ده كردوخ كردي كتاب يستحق القراءه وفي
معلومات مهمه جدا عن تركيا وما هو الكتاب
يا صديقي اي كتاب ابعث لي وقل لي حاضر
كتاب جديد عن تركيا يعني انت بعثت لمين
طيب
كتاب جديد عن تركيا ابعثه لي ثاني الاسم
حاضر وبعدين انت اسمك مميز كوردي يعني
استاذ سيد هل تعتقد ان الصحافه الغربيه
تتمتع فعلا بالحريه بان هذه مجرد شعارات
وكل صحيفه تاخذه اجندات الحكومه بشكل
مباشر غير مباشر الاجابه يا محمد نعم ولا
يعني انت لو بتتكلم على الصحافه في الدول
اللي هي كبيره عندها تجربه كبيره زي زي كل
الدول بقى الكبيره الولايات المتحده فرنسا
والمانيا
وبريطانيا
كل الدول ديت دول اوروبا الغربيه بصفه
عامه وفي دول ثانيه بس انت ما سالش عليها
زي الهندي
يعني
صحيفه مملوكه لرجال اعمال عندهم مصالح
معينه
عندهم الاجنده بتاعتهم في جهاد ثانيه
عندهم اجنده مختلفه لكن الحريه بتيجي منين
اولا هو في قدر من المهنيه اعلى بكثير من
عندنا فمهما كان هم عندهم اجندات يعني
مستوى التضليل اقل اقل من عندنا احنا
عندنا العمليه ماساويه جدا انما في حاجه
ثانيه
المناخل عام انه بيعرض لك سلع كثيره في اي
حد مهتم بانه يعرف معلومه هيسمع الراي
والراي الثاني وانت هتلاقي نفسك بتروح
للراي اللي انت مقتنع به يعني مثلا اي
قضيه هل والولايات المتحده مثلا هل دعمها
لاوكرانيا في صالح المواطن الامريكي على
سبيل المثال فبتلاقي انه في عدد كبير جدا
من الاعلام بيؤيد ده في عدد كثير ضده ما
حدش فاهمني على الاثنين ممكن ده يكون
مدفوع مثلا جمهوريين ضد الديمقراطيين او
العكس او اي مصالح اخرى امريكا بلد مفتوح
نفس القصه في بريطانيا نفس القصه في فرنسا
بتلاقي الاراء المختلفه موجوده وبالتالي
تقدر اذا بذلت مجهود انك توصل للمعلومه
افضل بكثير جدا من
الاوضاع في العالم العربي طبعا لو كنت
توهتك بعتذر بس اذا كانت اجابه مختصره نعم
اعتقد ان هناك حريات
خصوصا للشخص الواعي اللي عارف الجرنان ده
او المجله دي او التليفزيون ده بيعبر عن
مين فبتتوقع هو هيقول ايه
اخي همم
برايك ما الذي دار في الاجتماع الاخوه
اليوم في ابو ظبي لا اعلم يا صديقي كلام
اتابعه بعد احمد
ارجوك ارجو الجواب من تتوقع جاوبتها
السلام عليكم اخي الفاضل متى ممكن تنسحب
ما هو الموقف القانوني
في حال قيام الشعب المصري بسحب الثقه من
الرئيس والحكومه وعدم اعتقال اعترافه
بجميع الاتفاقات التي قامت به بهذه الحقبه
والله الموقف قانون الدولي لا بس انا ما
اعرفش ان القانون الدولي له علاقه بحاجه
زي كده يعني اي بلد بيحصل فيه زي ما انت
بتقول شعب كامل بينفض يده من حكومته
قانون الدولي ليس طرفا في هذه القصه انت
بتتكلم بقى في حاله انه اي دوله مصر او
غير مصر جاءت حكومه بتقول انا مش ملتزمه
بكل حكومات الاتفاقات السابقه ده سؤال
كبير قوي ويتوقف على الاتفاق اتفاقات حدود
مثلا ما تفرقش حكومه من الثانيه اتفاقيه
التوقيع ديون على حسب انت موقعها مع مين
مع دوله ولا مؤسسه فالسؤال النظري جدا يا
صديقي سامحني ومش عارف ايه دي اجابه تكون
معقوله يعني هنسرح في السيناريوهات خياليه
كثير
سيد سؤال ملح
ما مدى تاثير تراجع نفوذ الامريكي قد قوه
عظمى على على ارض الواقع حاليا وليس
مستقبلا برده على مصر ولا ما شاء الله
الحضور المصري كبير
تراجع نفوذ الامريكي قد قوه عظمى على ارض
الواقع طب ما نخليها على مصر وغير مصر ما
هو انت لما بتلاقي انت لما تكون مثلا
الولايات المتحده في 95 وفي سنه 2000 اذا
ارادت شيئا
يعني يعني لما هي حبت مثلا تاخذه العراق
ضد قناعه الصين ضد قناعه
روسيا اييه
وضد برده يعني على الاقل او عدم حماس
فرنسا يعني عمل الذهب لما حبت تتدخل في
حروب
البلقان او يوغسلافيا الدول يوغسلافيا
السابقه ضد رغبه الكثير من الدول في مجلس
الامن كونت تحالف وسميته تحالف همم افضل
دوله تحالف الراغبين
وكونت التحالف بتاعها وتدخلت وحسمت
الصناعه كما تشاء دلوقتي قدره الولايات
المتحده على عمل ده اقل لان في قوه اخرى
مستعد ان هي تتدخل وتلعب ادوار ما كانتش
بتلعب بها زي روسيا زي الصين زي الهند
وبالتالي لا يعني قدرتها على التاثير بيقل
الدول الاصغر بتلاقي الدول الكبيره ممكن
تدعمها ضد رغبات الولايات المتحده بس ما
تستفزش الولايات المتحده لدرجه يعني انه
يعني ما تعملش معها زي ما اوكرانيا عملت
مع روسيا والا هيكون مصيرك زي مصير
اوكرانيا
مضمون المؤتمر الصحفي لليفربول ممكن رؤيتك
وتحليلك لو تديني سؤال محدد يبقى كثر خيرك
لان لا خروف طوال الوقت وعلى مدى شهور
بيقول ان حرب اوكرانيا المساله لا تتعلق
باوكرانيا ولكنها مخطط غربي
لاسقاط روسيا واضعافها وطبعا ده كان رايه
قبل كده اكيد بعد الحرب ده يكون رايه اكثر
واكثر لانه عاوز يقول رساله للداخل الروسي
انه كل جند روسي بيموت مش لمجرد انه ده
نزوه او يعني همم
بسبب طموحات الرئيس الروسي او بسبب همم
اختر بيتوهما لا ده المساله اكبر بكثير من
اوكرانيا والغرب كله بيحاول اسقاط روسيا
بهذه الروايه اللي بيقولها الرئيس الروسي
طوال الوقت في الفتره الاخيره انه بيقول
احنا مستعدين للتفاوض والسلام بس بيعقبها
بمجموعه من التخيلات او الشروط اللي
معناها ان لا يمكن يكون فيه سلام لانه
بيقول له الاربع اقاليم اللي انا اخذتهم
منك دول خلاص اوكي ما تفكرش ابدا في شبه
جزيره القرم لازم لازم ان انت تنسى اي
تحالفات مع الغرب يعني بيحط مجموعه من
الشروط اللي مستحيل ممكن اي اوكرانيا
يقبلها طائعا يقبلها مرغما ماشي لكن لو
انت بتتكلم على نقطه محدده
اكون شاكر لو بعتني يعني
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد ممكن تتكلم عن وضع
العراق السياسي على فكره في صديق كان بعثت
من الجزاير انا والله ما شايف الرساله بس
اوصل لها لان دائما الناس بتتخيل انه اي
حاجه لكن انا هاوصل للرساله ان شاء الله
واقراها او يعني يبعثها ثاني لو بيحب يعني
السلام عليكم استاذنا
استاذنا ممكن تتكلم عن وضع العراق السياسي
اهل السيد السوداني يعد نقطه فارقه رجاء
استاذ لان حظي العراق من طرحكم السياسي
غير وفير يهمني رايكم لان انتم همم مثل
الله يخليك يا سيدي همم ده فاطمه الله
يخليك يا استاذ فاطمه انت بالعكس انا كان
عندي دعوه وكان المفروض انه عندي ندوه
والله في همم من احد المركز المحترمه مركز
الواقع يعني واظن كان في 18
ال- نوفمبر الماضي 18 ديسمبر الماضي
ولكن يعني شقه الظروف انه همم ما يحصلش
لكن انا كنت حاسس ان انا اقابل الناس في
العراق يعني وان شاء الله تتكرر قريبا
ونوح عنها انت بتسالي سيد السودانيه يكون
نقطه فرقه لا ما اعتقدش ان هيكون
مختلفارقه هيكون نقطه فرقه ازاي هو الراجل
همم مش تقليلا منه هو الراجل عنده مقعد او
مقعدين في البرلمان
يعني ما لوش هو قوى سياسيه همم بيمثلها
مثلا بحيث انه يقدر يفرض رؤيته هو زي اي
رئيس وزراء جاء في الفتره الاخيره لازم
يتم بالتوافق او عدم الممانعه يعني جهه
ممكن الجهاد تبارك وتصعب او جهاد تبارك
وجهات لا تمنع والجهات الاساسيه اللي بيتم
التوافق عليها طبعا في جهات داخليه وكمان
في جهات خارجيه زي ايران زي الولايات
المتحده زي همم دول الخليج بيكون لها راي
في القصه يعني انه مش انه يقولوا عينه
فلان ولكن ما يعملش عليه تحفرات ما يؤثرش
متاعب وطبعا الاكثر تاثيرا هم
همم الايران والولايات المتحده
لا اعتقد العراق مش هيقدر انه
الا اذا كان طبعا لله سبحانه وتعالى مش
هيقدر يتجاوز مشاكل كثيره جدا جدا
الا
بسيناريو تتحل فيه مشاكل الاقليم يعني هو
لوحده كده مش هيقدر خالص هو هيبقى عامل زي
ليبيا عامل زي سوريا مش هيقدر يتجاوز
مشكلاته الا اذا حصل هدوء في على مستوى
الاقليم ولما باقول هدوء على مستوى
الاقليم باتكلم على المشكله الكبيره اللي
تتعلق به اشتباك ايران مع كثير من الدول
المحيطه واللي عراق واحده من قصر هذه
المشاكل
ارجو الجواب ما انت جاوبناها الصحراء
الغربيه
مش فاهم يعني ايه السيد سؤال ملحمه مدى
تاثير اجابنا كيف ترى هل هناك ازمه مجبنه
هل تعتقد ان ده سؤال اي ام ار يو هل تعتقد
ان اسرائيل تستلم الشرق الاوسط بديلا عن
امريكا كما دخلت امريكا بديل الانتداب
البريطاني لا طبعا ما اعتقدش يعني اسرائيل
رغم ان هي يعني وهي دوله احتلال ما فيش شك
يعني هي دوله غير مقبوله مهما كان عندها
سلاح نووي مهما كان عندها تكنولوجيا اولا
هي صغيره جدا والحجم ده مؤثر يعني مش حاجه
قليله هم مدركين للقيود اللي عليهم القيود
الثقافيه ما حدش يقبل همم دوله مبنيه على
اساس ديني وهمم يعني دوله هيبقى مبنيه على
السنه دوله هيا يهوديه فعشان يبقى عندها
قبول في محيط كبير من العالم الاسلامي
والمسيحي صعب جدا هم مدركين ان هم دوله
احتلال وان هم موجودين لانهم متفوقين
عسكريا من الولايات المتحده وده الاخرى
وبالتالي ما فيش القبول ده في ازعاج
انما وحتى من حيث القوه هي تقدر تدافع عن
نفسها بدرجات المختلفه بالحق الاذى
بالاخرين لكن حتى دالي حدود وبالتالي اكثر
ازاي يعني ما تقدرش اسرائيلي تقدر خفيه
تروح وتقدم خدماتها لدوله عربيه تقدر خفيه
تبيع بعض منتجاتها في السلاح لكن تطلي هي
الدوله صغيره يعني
مرحبا بك يا استاذ سيد انا هل الافلام
اجابنا هل
سامي هل ستبقى الثقه في السلاح الروسي
خصوصا ما يجري في الحرب الاوكرانيه ما هو
ده بقى بياخذنا
لتقييم ما يجري في اوكرانيا وده باقي
بياخذنا برده للسؤال بتاع الاعلام انت
بتاخذ معلوماتك منين لو بتاخذ معلوماتك من
روسيا فانت صلح الروسي عظيم جدا لو بتاخذ
بقى من كثير من الوسائل الاعلام الغربيه
وهنا هما الحقيقه مضطرين ياخذوا من مصادر
حكومتهم لان مش كل وسائل الاعلام عندها
القدره تروح هناك وتقيم وتشوف والمساله
بتبقى سياديه حساسه شويه صعب ان هتلاقي
جريده مثلا انجليزيه ولا امريكيه يتكلم
على تفوق السلاح الروسي بشكل كاسا على
السلاح الامريكي صعبه يعني
ولكن وبالتالي انا مش عاوز افتي يعني ايه
ولكن اقدر اقول انه
يعني بعد حوالي سنه من القتال ممكن تقرا
الاحداث هناك اكثر من قراءه قراءه انه
الروس متعثرين بعد سنه في فرد رؤيتهم دي
قراءه فتقول ان السلاح الروسي متراجع
وقراءه ثانيه
وتراجعوا قدام مين قدام اوكرانيا في
الروايه الاولانيه الروايه الثانيه انه
روسيا في مواجهه كل دول حلف شمال الاطلسي
وعلى راسها الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وفرنسا والمانيا كل ده وهي قادره على الحق
ضرر ضخم بهمم وقادره حتى الان على السيطره
على ما عندهاش همم
هيمنه جويه لكن عندها السياده عندها سيطره
جويه من سياده يعني لسه الطيران الاوكراني
احيانا بيطلع ولكن هي اللي متسيده الاجواء
هي اللي مسيطره على معظم السواحل هي اللي
واخذه الاقاليم الاربعه فذلت من كميه
الاراضي اللي بتسيطر عليها لا يعني على
حسب انت هترى المسائل ازاي والافضل انك
تتجاوز التفاصيل ديت لانه المساله هتروح
وتجيء كثير وننتظر خلال العام الحالي يعني
والشهور المقبله التغيرات قد تكون مفاجاه
انما لو عاوز اجابه سريعه نعم ستبقى الثقه
في السلاح الروسي
ما هو مستقبل السيسي
تجرب في الهند تقرب في الشرق الاوسط اتجرب
في دول في حلف شمال الاطلسي زي اليونان
مثلا
السلاح الروسي جرف في اماكن كثيره
في الصين نفسها اللي بتشتري سلاح يعني
روسي بكميه كبيره تجرب في دول عربيه كثيره
جدا جدا عندك الجزائر بتحصل على اكثر من
70% من سلاحها من روسيا المغرب كانت بتحصل
على كميات ليست قليله من روسيا برده قبل
ان تتجه الى الولايات المتحده بشكل رئيسي
ما هو جديد
1986 ما هو مستقبل العولمه
هل صحيح انتهى عهد الوفره والرخاء لا
مستقبل العولمه الان في خطر العولمه كانت
توجهه موجود بيقول انه العالم سوف يكون
افضل من بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه هيكون
افضل لو ان الاسواق كلها انفتحت وزي ما
قلت لحضراتكم في حلقه سابقه اللي بشر
بالقصه ديت الدول
مش كل الدول كثير من الدول اللي انتصرت في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه اللي هي الدول
العربيه الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وفرنسا انما الدوله الاكبر في العالم كانت
هي اللي بتشر دلوقتي الولايات المتحده مش
مستفيده كثير من العولمه
الدول الغربيه تراجع نصيبها في التجاره
الدوليه زي بريطانيا وزي فرنسا
وبالتالي بقت في طيارات موجوده جوه
بيقولوا لهم احنا عاوزين نغلق اسواقنا
شويه عاوزين نغلق الهجره مش عاوزين
مهاجرين من بره احنا مش عاوزين ده جزء من
العولمه حريه انتقال الايدي العامله
وانتقال رؤوس الاموال وهكذا والبضائع مش
عاوزين
رؤوس الاموال تخرج بره وتبقى موجوده لدينا
علشان الرؤوس الاموال الغربيه بتروح
تستثمر في الصين والهند وبينج لاش عشان
العماله ارخص والضرائب اقل عاوزين الاماكن
هنا لانه في طبقه عامله وخاصه لما تركتش
تعليم كبير تاثرت وفقرت ووظيفها وظائفها
لصالح الطبقه المتوسطه والعمال الصينيين
وزادت الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه اللي خلت
الولايات المتحده عاوزه طفره سياج على
الصادراتها وتعاونها مع بلد كبير زي روسيا
والعكس وكمان مع الحرب التجاريه ما بين
الصين والولايات المتحده كل ده بيخلينا ان
العالم يكاد يعني ينقسم الى معسرين
والانقسام ده معناه ان سلاسل الامداد بدل
ما كانت الشركه تبقى في الولايات المتحده
او مقرها وبعدين يبقى المصنع موجود في
الصين
والمصنع ده مثلا مثلا كمبيوتر
من اليابان وتجيء له همم
عارف شرائح من تايوان وتجيء له همم ايدي
عامله مهندسين من اي بلد من اسبانيا وكلهم
يتجمعوا في مكان واحد من كل حته لا بيقول
لك انا عاوز اقلل سلاسل الامداد انقل
الصناعات الحيويه تبقى في دول حليفه او في
بلدي وده اللي بيسموه لاي شور عكس افشور
اوف شور يعني العولمه ان المصنعه تبقى
بعيده موجوده حيث
العماله ارخص وحيث العائد على الاستثمار
اكبر الاي شور لا انا اجيب التكنولوجيا
والمصانع بتاعتي في دول صديقه او على
ارضيه حتى ولو كانت الاستثمارات العائد
عليها اقل علشان اكون مسيطر عليها وما
يحصلش زي ما حصل مثلا في روسيا انه تقوم
الحرب وسيطروا على مصنعي او انه بلد زي
الصين تصعد على اكتافي
هل الطاقه المتجدده والخضراء والهيدروجين
سترى النور قريبا هي رات النور
كبديل للغاز
ولكن انه يكون بديل تام يعني نستغنى عن
الغاز والبترول الاجابه لا الهيدروجين
الاخضر ولا الازرق ولا
لا يعني الازرق جزء من الطاقه شويه
الاحفوريه يعني كل مصادر الطاقه المتجدده
اذا كان هيدروجين اخضر بيتم توليده بمصادر
الطاقه نظيفه اول همم الرياح او الشمس الى
اخره لا تستطيع دلوقت وقال سنتين ثلاثه
اربعه ما اعرفش طبعا العلم يتوقف على تطور
العلم ما تقدرش ت- همم
يعني تحل محل البترول والغاز ده اللي اتضح
للعالم تماما تماما يعني لكن العلم بيمشي
ما هو ممكن حد يعني بعد شهرين يلاقي وسيله
فعاله ابتكار
يمكنه هذا يمكن البشريه يمكن هذا الابتكار
البشريه من تخزين الطاقه الشمسيه من تخزين
طاقه الرياح ما هي المشكله انه يلاقي يعني
طريقه فعاله لتخزين الطاقه وبالتالي
استخدامها حين تريد اذا توصلوا الى هذه
التكنولوجيا وباسعار مقبوله اه طبعا هيحصل
يبقى تطور خطير تابعه مساله تطور
الابتكار في وسائل التخزين البطاريات
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد قبيل تصغير الجبل
ماشي سيد الكريم انا فعلا
سيد الكريم سؤالي ما ده يماني سؤالي ما
سبب كثره الاسئله الاقتصاديه والاهتمام
الاقتصادي من المتابعين الكرام ولماذا
اصبحت قضايا الامه مثل فلسطين مهمله جدا
دي طول عمرها يا صديقي يعني انت
انت بتهتم يعني
بالشؤون الخارجيه لما تكون يعني امن يعني
امن من الجوع وتشعر بالاطمئنان يعني
يعني انت يعني يعني تخيل مثلا لما تكون
انت في بلد انت مصدر دخلك كويس وانت
والبلد مستقر فانت تقدر تناقش قضايا فيها
همم خلاف الاكل والشرب اللي هو عصب الحياه
والامن طبعا
انما اذا كنت انت مهدد في رزقك واذا كنت
انت خائف من الاضطرابات اللي موجوده في
البلد بتنكافئ على نفسك وبالتالي الطبيعي
انه
قضايا الامه كما تشير يعني تحتل رقم 2 و 3
لما بيكون الناس مش لاقيه فرص او مهدله في
ارزقها يعني الكلام ده مش في العالم
العربي الكلام ده في اي مكان الكلام ده
يعني يعني حاجه غريزيه مرحبا استاذ سيد
انا جبت
استاذ بدي اسالك شو يلي يمنع امريكا من
طبعه دولارات اكثر طالما الطلبه عليها
كثير ده احمد محمد ما فيش حاجه بتمنعها
طبعا بس لما تطبع كثير قوي زي ما حصل في
الثانويه
اكثر من اي وقت من 40 سنه لما برده كانوا
طبعه كثير هتطبع كثير يعني هيبقى عندك
تضخم التضخم ده معناها
اموال كثيره جدا
بتطالب بضائع قليله جدا معنى كده ان
التضخم او ارتفاع الاسعار بيحصل في سوره
البسيطه في حالتين
البضائع زي ما هي بس الاموال تدفقت عن غير
طريق الانتاج يعني طبيعته مثلا اقترضت
مثلا فده لازم يؤدي الى بقت فيه فلوس
كثيره لكن البضائع زي ما هي نفس عدد
الاقلام نفس عدد الخضروات الفاكهه
البيوت الى اخره او اللي يحصل ان الاموال
ما زادتش لكن البضائع قلت ما عدتش بتبني
بيوت زي الاول ما عدتش بتزرع خضروات او
بتنتج اا سلع زي الاول وبالتالي اذا هي
اللي بيمنعها
فكره انه تخشى انه عملتها تفقد قيمتها
وبالتالي تضيع كل شيء يعني
اسئله متكرره
يعني قلتهم بالفعل ماذا تستفيد امريكا
مساء الخير ممكن حلقه
مساء الخيرات
ده القدم ماذا تستفيد امريكا من نشر
الشدود في العالم ولماذا لها مؤيدون
كثيرين ومتى تتوقف عن نشرها
في حلقه كامله ادهم ده ادهم ان في حلقه
كامله عن القصه ديت
وانا بتعجب والله العظيم يعني
بفتكر كلام ابن خلدون
بس انا لا اذكره نصا لان انا قريته
يعني من فتره طويله ان الامم لما بتمر
بمراحل بعد الامم اللي بتنجح وبتبني
ببلدانها يعني بتبقى امم مكافحه وبعدين
بتناضل جدا فبتشتغل ويبقى عندها جهاز
انتاج ضخم وهو ما قالش كده ابن خلدون
الجهاز انتاج لكن بعد كده بتبقى امم مرفقه
الرفاهيه ديت زي الامبراطوريه الرومانيه
والغرب يعني مجنون بالامبراطوريه
الرومانيه واسباب سقوطها بيبقى عندك طبقه
مرفقه مشغوله بقضايا يعني
ما تستحقش كل هذا الاهتمام يعني احيانا
يعني من بعض اهتمامات النخب وبعض اهتمامات
الغربيين مش كلهم يعني
بيستدعي الصور اللي قرات عنها في التاريخ
الروماني ناس مهتمه بامور يعني انا بافتح
الاقامه مستنيه امبارح او اول امبارح
ولقيت فكره العلاقات المتعدده في نفس ال-
همم
انت شرها ايه العلاقات المتعدده يعني مثلا
احنا عندنا هنا في العالم الاسلامي ان
راجل يتجوز سيدتين او ثلاثه او اربعه يعني
وفقا للشرع وده هم ممبوب جدا عندهم
انما هم بيقولوا فكره التعدديه ان الطرف
يبقى عنده اكثر من شركه يعني سيده تعيش مع
زوجين او زوج يعيش مع زوجتين وهكذا يعني
وطبعا بما ان هم في اكتر من دوله وفي اكثر
من ولايه داخل كل دوله زاويات المتحده
بتقبل به الزواج المثليين فممكن تبقى
علاقه ثلاثيه همم ربما اكتر من نفس الجنس
يعني انا حطيت كل ال يعني الاجابات يعني
ممكن استنتجها في حلقه لماذا
كل هذا الدفاع عن حقوق المثليين الحقيقه
مش فاكر العنوان الحلقه بس استاذنك ارجع
لها ولو في حاجه ناقصه استاذنك قول لي
وانا اجتهد يعني
اخونا ممم
مناف او استاذنك كده وتكتبه بالعربي
سؤالي عند الطلائع على
الجذب لسوريا ال جي بي الجديد 2010 كان
يفوق 258 مليار دولار
ويفق حتى اسرائيل وفقا لاحساءه البنك
الدولي ما هو الفرق مع
بي بي الذي تتفوق فيه
انا مش متاكد لو كتبتها يعني لو كتبت
الحاجات بس اللي بتشير اليها بالانجليزي
اكون شاكر اولا انا شاكك في الرقم 258
مليار دولار
258 دولار لسوريا سنه 2010 اشك في هذا
الرقم يعني لو حد ممكن يعمل سيرش كده عن
الناتج المحلي لسوريا سنه 2010 و يتاكد من
هذا الرقم انا اشك في هذا الرقم
ده اولا يعني
اعتقد انه اكبر من قدره سوري ان يكون على
هذا الرقم في سنه 2010
ناتج المحلي الاجمالي بتاعها تقريبا قد
الامارات في حدود 400 مليار دولار اذا ما
كانش يعني رقم مش
اذا ما خنتنيش الذاكره انا بستنتج من
سؤالك انك بتسال عن الفرق ما بين
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الفرق ما بين
البيبي
انا سامحني مش فاهم السؤال معلش انا مش
فاهم السؤال انا ممكن استنتج بتسال عن
الفرق ما بين التقدير الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بالقيمه الاسميه
والناتج المحلي الاجمالي
البيرج سينج باور بارتي بالقدره الشرعيه
حفترض ده وهجاوبه
اي دوله بيجمعوا عدد يعني بيشوفوا اجمالي
ما تنفقه الدوله اجمالي ما تنتجه الدوله
من سبع وخدمات في السنه وبيقيم طبعا
بعملتها وبعدين بيحول الى الدولار وفقا
لسعر الصرف وبيقول مثلا انه بلد زي
الامارات في حدود 400 مليار دولار هي مش
بتنتج محسبهاش هما بالدولار يعني هم
حسبوها الاول
بالعمله الاماراتي وبعدين بيحولوها الى
الدولار وبالتالي طريقه سعر الصرف هنا
بيفرق
سندباد مش بيحسبها كده بيقول انا الدينار
عندي بيشتري ايه في بلدي والدولار بيشتري
ايه في الولايات المتحده فاحيانا تبقى
بالحساب القوه الشرائيه انا عايش كويس
بعدد بما يوازي عدد اقل من الدول العربيه
ببساطه لانه مثلا في بلد زي همم
مثلا زي السودان زي مثلا بلد زي مصر بلد
زي ممكن تكون تقدر تستعين بكل خدمات
المهنيين من المدرسه
قليل جدا تقدر تركب تاكسي انا اقدر هنا في
القاهره اركب تاكسي مهما غله الاسعار
بقيمه لا تقارن ابدا بالتكسي في الولايات
المتحده اقدر استعين بطبيب كويس بقيمه
اللي بكتير من اللي ممكن يتقادات طبيب
الامريكي في الولايات المتحده
لكن اذا وضحت لي اكثر انا تحت امرك حد كشف
على الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لسوريا في
السلام عليكم همم
ناصر همم
المهندس ناصر السلام عليكم استاذ سيد
تحياتي لك سؤالي بخصوص سياسه دوله
الامارات وتقاربها مع الجميع السعوديه
وايران وامريكا وروسيا البحرين وقطر وقصه
على ذلك انا تفسيري في هذا يا صديقي انه
الامارات
عندها سياسه
بتسير على يعني فكرتين
الفكره الاولانيه الشعور بالخطر اللي تربى
عندهم من بعد غزوه العراق له الكويت
واللي زاد مع احداث العالم المختلفه
وادركه انه انا لازم
ادافع عن امن القومي بوسائل مختلفه من ضمن
الوسائل المختلفه ديت تنويع الحلفاء والا
تضع نفسك كما فعل الدول الاخرى اخرها همم
اخرها ايه انا الاسم طرمز البلد اسمها ايه
روسيا بتضربها اسمها ايه اوكرانيا
انك ايوه تستعين بحلفاء زي الولايات
المتحده بل تذهب الى اكثر من ذلك في انك
انت تقيم علاقات مع اسرائيل لكن في نفس
الوقت تحاول تقنع ايران انك لا تستهدفها
مش دائما السياسه دي بتنجح لكن حتى الان
هي ناجحه مع الامارات
عملتها قطر بس بشكل اقل
وضوحا يعني سبقتها في القصه ديت فان عملت
علاقات مع اسرائيل بس بدون تطبيقه وعملت
علاقات وشركات مع ايران وكانت رفض مثلا
انه هو
تنضم الى معسكر
يستهدف ايران يعني ده تفسيره بسيط انا مش
عاوز اكون طرف في معسكر انا عاوز مدير كل
علاقاتي بشكل ما يخلينيش في فوهات مدفعه
لان انا مهما كنت غني مهما كنت بلد يعني
برحب بالابتكار في الاخر انا محاط بمجموعه
من القوه اللي هي اكبر مني ولا داعي
الاستعداد السبب الثاني هو انه مش كل
الامارات اللي همم كل همم الامارات يعني
الامارات المكونه لدوله الامارات غنيه وهم
ارادوا تنويع اقتصادهم من وقت مبكر
وبالتالي هم بيدوروا على فرص الربح فين
فيدركه جيده جدا انه العلاقه باكبر عدد من
الدول باقل قدر من المشكلات ده يفتح لهم
فرصه للتجاره مع هذه الدول
اااه استاذ سيد سؤال ملحم ما مدى تاثير
اجبناه تاثير التراجع لان المفروض
الامريكي احمد الغزال حذف الرساله تقريبا
ياسر عمر استاذ السيد
لتميزك وابداعك في تخيل الاحداث باسلوب
بسيط وموضوع واحيالي ودقيق هو جعلنا نطمع
في ان تخصص لنا حلقه تجيب فيها الله يخليك
اشكرك ربنا يخليك من غير طمع ولا حاجه
يسعدني ياسر
السيد واعتني بحلقه عن الشرح بين الاحزاب
اليمنيه واليساريه والشرعيه والفرق بينهم
الحديث عن الاحزاب بشكل عام على الاقل
بالدول والله كنت بتكلم عليها من حوالي
اقل من اسبوع بس ما كانش يعني في على
الهواء انا ممكن ادي لك اجابه سريعه
وبعد كده حاضر يعني اليمين واليسار ده
الاجابه عليه يعني سهله قوي وصعبه قوي هي
سهله لما اا لما تبدا البدايه البسيطه
يعني انك تعرف الاساسيات وبعد كده كل حاجه
بتتفرع هي القصه بدات منين اليمين ولا
اليسار بدات بالثوره الفرنسيه
انه بعد ما قامت الثوره الفرنسيه كان في
خلاف على هل نبقي على صلاحيات الملك
المطلقه كما كانت قبل الثوره ام نقللها
فدخل الناس الممثلين كل اعضاء البرلمان او
ما يسمى الجمعيه الوطنيه في فرنسا
اللي
مؤيدين للملك
والابقاء على صلاحيته المطلقه جلسوا على
اليمين والناس المعارضين اللي بيمثلوا
الثوره جلسوا على الشمال اذا تصورت الصوره
ديت كل شيء هيكون سهل بعد كده لانه اللي
بيدعم الملك كان بيمثل الستاتس قوه
المحافظين انا عاوز امثل
ادعم استمرار القيم السائده في المجتمع ما
هي القيم السائده بالفرنسيه
بدعم الملكيه
بدعم ااا
عدم الثوره عليه في مقابل اليسار اللي هو
بيدعم الثوره التغيير الجمهوريه وليس
الملك مش عاوز يحافظ على
مصالح طبقه النبلاء والامراء عاوز يسمح
الثوار ان هم ياخذوا فرصه اكبر ليه الترقي
في المجتمع وبالتالي دائما اليمين في اي
دوله لما تسمع كلمه يمين يعني مرتبط
بالمحافظه اذا كان مثلا في امريكا يبقى
الجمهوريين هو المحافظين اللي بيقول لك
انا ارفض مثلا انا بدافع عن قيم الكنيسه
مش لازم يكون بيروح يصلي ولكن مثلا هيرفض
الاجهاض باعتباره ان ده ضد قيم المسيحيه
هيرفض مثلا زواج المثليين في الغالب لان
ده ضد
الثقافه التقليديه
هيوافق مثلا على فكره انتشار السلاح لان
ده من مبادئ الدستور ومن اسس الدوله
الامريكيه ودي قصه طويله هتلاقي على
المقابل بقى هتجد انه اليسار لا هو ممكن
يوافق على الاجهاض لانه من انصار الحريه
شبه المطلقه هتلاقي انه لا يمانع في زواج
المثليين هتجد انه اليمين ممكن يبقى همم
يتقبل فكره مش هيقول التمييز العنصري ما
حدش يقدر يقول كده ولكن هيبقى
مثلا ضد المهاجرين يعني متفهم قوي ان في
غضب ضد المهاجرين ضد الاقل هيات متفهم اذا
ماكانش معهم الجنسيه انا بتكلم على التيار
المعلن تحت ممكن بيني وبين نفسه يبقى ضد
السود ضد العرب ضد غيره بس ده حاجه بيني
وبين نفسه
اليسار يرحب بالمهاجرين وعلى اساس ان
المساوادي قيم مطلقه ده بصفه عامه كده
يعني الاجابه سريعا لكن ايه برده هي زي
السؤال اللي طرحته وبتاع انا وعدتكم
بحكايه المشتقات الماليه وليامين ولاسار
كده الاجابه دي وضحت شويه ولا انا صعبت
عليك المسائل انا باقول بعد كده ان هي
بتبقى اصعب شويه ليه لانه احيانا بتجد ان
اليمين نفسه يعني مش بالبساطه دي مين اقرب
شويه لليسار ويسار اقرب شويه لليمين في
شويه العمليه مش بتبقى يعني بهذا
الامر شديد الوضوح
كيف ترى مستقبل تونس السياسي اجبناه
السلام عليكم بصير اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
في لبنان
نسال الاول عن مصير لبنان لان الوضع في
لبنان بارق الصعوبه فاذا كانت صعبه على
اللبنانيين اكيد صعبه على الفلسطينيين
برايك ما هي التوابع وصول السيد مكرسي
لمجلس النواب
ما عنديش اجابه اقدر اقول لك انه رئيس
مجلس النواب هيترتب على وجوده ما عنديش
المعلومه قد يكون انه يكون في تغيير كبير
في السياسات لانه في الاخر بيعبر عن
الجمهوريين يعني
ما اعتقدش انه هم
وبعدين انت بتسال برده على اساس الخارجيه
ولا السياسه الداخليه
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد تحياتي لحضرتك من
انجلترا احنا اجابنا السؤال السلام عليكم
على ياسين ما رايك بانضمام اوكرانيا الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي ده مصطفى حسبه توقع هنري
كيسنجر الاخير انا ما اعرفش ان هن تتوقع
ان هي تنضم لحلف شمال الاطلسي واذا تتوقع
ده يبقى شيء في منتهى الغرابه يعني
بالمناسبه في كلام كثير
لكن في كل الاحوال يعني ايه هتنضم لحلف
شمال الاطلسي انا ممكن افهم انه يعيدوها
بالدعم عشان تنضم لحلف شمال الاطلسي لازم
الدول ال 30 يوافقوا ولازم لما يوافقوا
يكون فيه سبب انها تكون اضافه انسى ان هي
تم تحطيمها
وانسى ان هي دوله تحتاج الى سنين طويله
جدا حتى تعود اذا ساعدوها وهذه المساعده
سوف تكون محل جدل يعني مش كل الدول هتبقى
مستعده في هذه الازمه الاقتصاديه انها
تدفع
مليارات الدولارات يعني تقدير مش هيقل عن
500 مليون
6500 مليار 600 مليار وفي تقديرات وصلت
الى تريليون
لكن
في تحفظات اصلا على انضمام اوكرانيا الحلف
شمال الاطلسي على المدى المنظور
لانه هي لازم يبقى بترقى لمعايير
اللي حطها حلف شمال الاطلسي من ان
المدنيين هم اللي يتحكموا في السياسه
الدفاعيه من نسبه الانفاق على السلاح من
مستوى الشفافيه هو الديمقراطيه حاجات
كثيره بيحطوها يعني وبالتالي
يعني انا استبعد هذا يعني
واستاذنك تتاكد ان هنكسنجر قال كده ولو
كان قال كده بيتكلم ايه على المدى البعيد
50 سنه مثلا ولا ايه احمد محمد انا هل
ستكون حرب بين المغرب والجزائر تصعيد خطير
جدا بينهما لا حرب ما فيش حد اي حد متابع
الشان الجزائري والمغربي يتوقع حربا ولكن
العلاقات متوتره وده بينعكس على علاقتهم
مع اوروبا مع افريقيا كل دوله بتحاول ان
هي تسجل نقاط على الاخرى
لكن ما فيش هناك ما يستدعي حرب بين
البلديه الجزائر قطعت العلاقه ما فيش
علاقات دبلوماسيه من اغسطس 21
الحدود مغلقه بشكل شبه منتصف من 94 ايه
دائما كل بلد في سباق تسلح كل دوله
بتستهدف الاخرى يعني الجزائر طلبت سخويا
57 اللي هي اكثر مقاتلات روسيا تقدما
هي تعقلت على 35 وبعدين قيل ان هي قالت
انا عاوزه افضل المغرب بتحاول تحصل على اف
35 من امريكا وهكذا يعني
فالاجابه المختصره ما فيش اصل الحرب هتعمل
ايه يعني لما اقول لفترض ان في العادات
التوتر موجود والدبله العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مقطوعه بس لما يترتبش عليه
حرب اصل الحرب هتعمل ايه انت لما بتحارب
بتحط هدف ايه الهدف اللي ممكن الحرب تعمله
انت الجزائر بتقول ان المغرب بيستعديني
وبيمارس ضدي مجموعه من السياسات المعاديه
بدءا من تشجيع مثلا منطقه القبائل على
الانفصال على حرق الغابات على التجسس على
المسؤولين على على اوكي اذا قامت حرب يعني
هيحصل ايه يعني يعني انا انت لما تقوم حرب
بتدمر الدوله كلها بتسقط يعني مش هيحصل
الكلام ده في الحرب بيكون لها سبب يعني
انا لما هاخذ حرب اهداف في ايه من الدوله
اللي ولو كل دوله جارتها عامله لها متاعب
حربه العالم كله حرب العالم كله تقريبا
يعني
هل صحيح ان هناك مؤشرات حقيقيه عن
المستقبل الاقتصادي سيكون في الشرق الاوسط
وان الاقتصاد الاوروبي سيتاثر سلبا
مش مش مساله المستقبل الاقتصادي يعني في
الشرق الاوسط الشرق الاوسط الشرق الاوسط
ده منطقه كبيره تقصد ايران تقصد تركيا
تقصد باكستان تقصد دول الخليج يعني وبعدين
كل واحد له ظروفه يعني هو الشرق الاوسط
عنده مزايا انه غني بالطاقه وبعد كثير من
دول فده بيدي له ميزه في ايام ال- همم
يعني ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه على الاقل في
المدى المنظور يعني سنه سنتين
عنده مصادر طاقه متجدده الشمس والرياح الى
اخره يعني اما الاقتصاد الاوروبي سوف
يتاثر سوف يتاثر بس هي دي قوه اقتصاديه
كبرى كتله اقتصاديه كبيره فلما يتاثر
معناها انه مش هينمو بنفس المعدل وان
الرخاء اقل بس مش معناها انهم يكون
اوضاعهم اسوا من الشرق الاوسط ولا افريقيا
اليسا انا حتى الان بدور على السؤال اخونا
الجزائري اللي تاه مني ومش لاقيه الا اذا
كنت انت سحبت سؤالك
ليس من افضل اليس من الافضل لروسيا ان
تخضع للغرب بل افضل طرفين بل افضل
للطرفيني هل سبب العدوات بين الطرفين
الافضل لترفين ما هو سبب العلاوات بين
طرفينها الروسيا لديها مشروع توسعي
لهذا توجد توترات الاجابه في حلقه كامله
عن سر يعني انا عامل حلقه كامله حوالي 30
دقيقه
استاذنك ارجع لها انا مش فاكر بالضبط بس
اظن ما سر العداء التاريخي بين روسيا
والولايات المتحده
ورصدت فيها التطور التاريخي للخلاف اللي
موجود بينهم في استاذنك ارجع للحلقه ولو
انت وجدت صعوبه في انك تلاقي الاسم انت
لما تبحث في تكتب كلمه روسيا وتطلع كل
الحلقات هتلاقي الحلقه فيها الاجابه كامله
بس الاجابه لك يعني الاجابه السريعه لا مش
الافضل للرساله هنا بتاخد على الغرب الغرب
اللي يرضيه من روسيا انه تقريبا يفتتها
انه يضعفها انه يجعلها دوله ستالايت او
تابعه له في دول امكانياتها ما تسمحلهاش
انها تكون دوله تابعه صوره الذهنيه لشعبها
على نفسها ما يقبلش ان يكون دوله صغيره
روسيا ده امكانيات ضخمه جدا دوله عندها
فيديو في مجلس الامن عندها
الترسانه نوويه هي الاكبر في العالم دوله
عندها ايه يعني ثروات ضخمه جدا دوله عندها
حاجات كثير وبالتالي ايه اللي يجعلها
تخدعني ثم لو خضع تفتكر هيكون مصيرها افضل
من دول خضعت وتم تجريدها من كل شئ يعني
بس كمان الغرب مش هيستفيد يعني انه يوافق
انه روسيا تاخد اوكرانيا وتاخذ المانيا
ماشي مش هينفع الكلام ده يعني انما هو
توازن القوه هو اللي ممكن يحفظ مصالح
الطرفين واحنا ما لناش مصالح مع الطرفين
احنا عايزين مصالحنا ما هو الموقف القانون
الدولي في حلقه ايام اجابنا هل هناك ازمه
اجبنا
جنه الحياه هل التقارب التركي السوري
سياره النور ام النفق المظلم والله النفخ
في التقدير يعني الاجابه سريعه الله اعلم
بس قد يرى النفقه المظلم واذا راى الحياه
ممكن يبقى جزء صغير جدا انت اعتقد انت شفت
الحلقه يعني انه ما يطلبه الرئيس التركي
يعني بصراحه مستفز يعني هو قضى سنوات في
محاوله الاسقاط بشار الاسد اوكي هذا حقك
انت ترتب على السياسه ديت انه كنت تعتقد
ان ده سوف يكون في صالح تركيا وفي صالح
تصوراتك انت اللي ادارتك المنطقه ان انا
اسكت بشار اجيب نظام يكون متوافق مع
تصوراتي وتبقى سوريه امتداد ليا وممكن
اسيطر على شمال سوريا كان عنده تصورات
كبيره جدا في تغيير كل منطقه الشرق الاوسط
ويكون هو يعني عاصمه همم
لكل هذه الدول
سقت المسائل وصلت في غيري مجرياتها
وزي ما يقولوا كده يعني لم تسر السفن على
الرياح على ما يشتهي دلوقتي ترتب على
سيادته عنده حوالي ثلاثه ونصف ولا اربعه
مليون
الاتراك مش عاوزينهم لان ظروفهم
الاقتصاديه بقت صعبه ترتب عليه انه عنده
استنزاف لقدراته وقوته في ااا شمال سوريا
ترتب عليه انه الامن عنده ما هواش فيه
احسن احواله
امور كثيره ما هياش في صالحه يعني وعلي
ايه دلوقتي هو عاوز بشار الاسد عشان تروح
لبشار الاسد او اي رئيس يعني لازم تقول له
تقدم له حاجه ايه اللي ممكن تقدمه له هو
ما بيقدمش حاجه هو بيقول انا عاوز اقعد
معك اقعد معاك وبعدين نتفاوض انك تلبي له
الامور اللي انا شايف ان هي في مصلحه
بينه وبين بشار الاسد
ونقط التقاط مع الدول الاخرى اللي هي لها
يعني
ليها قول مهم في الشان السوري زي ايران
وزي روسيا والولايات المتحده يعني بس
اعتقد ان في حلقه يعني ممكن حضرتك ترجع
لكل تفاصيلها حلقه من حوالي اسبوعين ثلاثه
يعني
لماذا يلحق اظن اردوغان على لقاء الاسد
موري استاذ سيد سؤال ملحمه ماذا تاثير
تراجع النفوذ الامريكي جابناها السيد ما
توقعاتك لسعر الصرف في مصر ما عنديش
توقعات لسعر الصرف المصري لانه دلوقت خلاص
وطبعا في اجابات يعني احنا جبناها في كذا
حلقه سعر الصرف في مصر وفقا للمعلم من
البنك المركزي هو الدوله المصريه انه يترك
للعرض والطلب
البديل هنا لما يترك للعرب للعرض والطلب
ده معناه بعد فتره كان في كميات كبيره جدا
من الطلبات المتاخره للمستوردين
ويعني القلق اللي كان موجود في السوق انه
يحصل عمليه زي ما بيقولوا كده اوفر شوتين
كانه يحصل السعر يعني
ثلاث شويه ما اعرف اذا كان الثاني ولا لا
بس تقدر تتوقع انه يكون في تذهب كثير جدا
يفترض ان السعر ده ايه ده لو البنك
المركزي لو الحكومه المصريه قدرت تنجح في
انها تدير العمليه كلها
جيد يعني انها تقدر تقنع صندوق النقد
الدولي اللي انا مكمله في البرنامج وتقدر
تقنع جهات اخرى ان هي تقرضها تقدر كمان
تقنع مستثمرين سواء يقرضوها في الاموال
الساخنه او مستثمرين بجد يجوا يعملوا
عندها استثمارات تقدر تجد مشتريين جديد
همم
[موسيقى]
يعني همم مشتريين او مستثمرين راغبين في
شراء اصول معروضه للبيع كل دي مش اسرار ده
هو ده المطروح تقدر تتجاوز
اداره الازمه واثارها الصعبه على المصريين
لانه انت بعد شويه يكون عندك
خطوه الحكومات عاده بتعملها اذا انت
ارتبطت به
اتفاق مع الصندوق انك هترفع اسعار
المحروقات ترفع اسعار الكهرباء هتزود
الرسوم والضرائب دي كلها قرارات لها تاثير
صعب جدا ازاي هدرها كل ده يتوقف على قدره
الحكومه ومهرتها في اداره هذه المرحله
بالغه الصعوبه انا كل ما اجاوب السؤال ده
باجد نفسي بيجي لي مجموعه من التعليقات
واضطر ان انا يكون اجابتها
انا او غيري لما بتتكلم على القصه دي احنا
بنتكلم على الوضع اللي موجود في انت
بتسالني دائما السؤال طب وامتى نتخلص من
القروض وانت انا معك والله يا ريت بس ده
ما حصلش ودلوقتي صعب انه يحصل قبل ما
تتخلص يعني تتصلح الامور دي اولا يعني انت
في الوضع اللي انت فيه مش هتقدر تكتب
استثمارات بجد في الوضع اللي انت فيه مش
هتقدر تعمل صناعه وزراعه وتكتزن تمارين
هتضطر الاول انك تتجاوز المرحله اللي انت
فيها بلاغه الدقه وبعد كده اذا حصل نجاح
في اداره هذه المرحله يبقى المفروض نتعلم
او الحكومه تتعلم من اخطائهم من اخطاء
حكمات سباقاتها وتبتدي تشوف ايه الاخطاء
اللي ادت الى الازمه الحاليه ايه الاسباب
اللي ادت الى الازمه التي سبقتها والمفروض
انه علجت في 2016 وايه الاسباب اللي سبقت
كل هذه الازمات على مدار 50 سنه واضح في
باترن سابق وفي عدد من الاقتصاديين
المحترمين جدا كنت باكلم واحد منهم صباح
اليوم الدكتور ابراهيم العيسوي واختصادي
انا يعني همم باتشرف بان انا اعرفه اسمع
له اقتصادي كبير عنده رؤيه مختلفه
وشايف انه عنده رؤيه لضروره اعاده النظر
في كثير من الاولويات الاقتصاديه الموجوده
والتوجهات الاقتصاديه الموجوده لمصر
والدول ناميه كثيره تحتاجها تحتاج لاعاده
النظر في كل الاولويات ديه وان هي ازاي هي
تقدر تحاول ان هي تركز على ان تكون دوله
انتاجيه دوله وفره وزي تقدر تعمل ده علشان
ما تكررش نفس المشكله كل مره ان انا اقع
في مشكله واحاول اسدد الديون واحاول اجد
وسيله لاقناع مؤسسه ماليه باقراضي ت- تهدى
ال- الازمه نسبيا ثم تعود الي بعد سنه
سنتين
رايك بالقمه التي صارت اليوم في ابو ظبي
لم اتابعها اسف فهد بس اللي هي حاضر يعني
اتابعها واعرف ايه يعني وبعدين ان شاء
الله في اقرب فرصه
الحرب عربيه اسرائيليه وارده عربيه
اسرائيليه صعبه انما حرب بين اسرائيل
واطراف عربيه وارده جدا
تحيه لك اخي هل المغرب يعيشوا ازمه
اقتصاديه شبيهه بمصر لا ما اعتقدش ان هي
شبيهه بالازمه المصريه
لماذا لم تحضر السعوديه اجتماع انا اسف
نفس الاجتماع انتم بتتكلموا النهارده على
اجتماع ابو ظبي في اسم حولي
وتابع مجرى انا لم اتابع ما جرى فيها حتى
يعني ايه
عشان ما اقولش كلام انا مش عارفه فانا مش
عارف اللي حصل في القمه احتاج ان انا
اعرفها الاول واتابعها
ونتواصل مع بعض اصدقاءنا يعني قريبين من
القصه ونعرف وبعدين اتكلم مع حضراتكم
استاذ سيد
لما تحرس الدوله المتقدمه على ضمن حقوق
الانسان لشعوبها ولكن هي في الوقت نفسه
تعتمد على حقوق الشعوب الاخرى
هل هذا يعني ان شعارات حقوق الانسان التي
تقوم برفعها مجرد شعارات كاذبه وظيفه ايوه
طبعا ياسر شعرات كاذبه وسائقه يعني ههه
في نفس الاسبوع
سمير هاني
اللي متجوز الممثله الامريكيه اللي كتب
الكتاب مذكراته لما يقول ان انا بيتكلم
على
يعني عمليه القتل اللي قتلهم في افغانستان
بالاباتشي اللي كان راكبها
وغيره بيتكلم لما تطلع تسريبات على الماسي
اللي ارتكبوها في قتل الناس في كل حته ده
انا عادي خالص لكن لما بيقولوا
انه ايران
شنقت مسؤول سابق عندها
والمشكله ان المسؤول السنه دي ان هو كان
معاه الجنسيه المستوى يعني لو مكانش معه
الجنسيه المزدوجه كانه كان معه باسورد
بريطانيا اقل يعني بشاعه وهل سواء كان
معالجه الجنسيه او مش معه انا ما بقولش ان
دي جريمه ولا لا انا ما كنتش جزء من
القبائل
الايراني ولا اعرف اذا كان الرجل يستحق
الاعدام ولا لا انا باتكلم على رد الفعل
الغربي المباراه
في بئر الغاز الاخير المكتشفه في مصر
انتهت انتبهت ان الشركتين اجنبيتين تمتلك
كل واحده من 45 في المئه والشركه المصريه
10% ده في عمليه الاستكشاف يعني الشركات
اللي بتستكشف بتاخد جزء
نفترض ان شركه واحده بتاخذ حصه
وبعد كده الحصه للبلد يعني انت صاحب الحقل
بتستعين بشركه او بمجموعه شركات الشركات
ديت هتتولى عمليه الاستكشاف والحفر وبعدين
تاخذ نسبه من العائد وانت كدوله بتاخذ جزء
من العائد فسواء كانت شركه او عدد شركات
دي هم اللي هيقوموا بالمجهود يطلعوا بقى
فرنسيين يطلعوا مصريين يطلعين كل واحد
يعني قدرته انه يقنع الدوله اللي عندها
البئر يعني
صاحبه الارض
اخي هل يوجد بند دفاع مشترك بين الدول
العربيه وان كان يوجد لماذا لا يتم تفعيله
لا يوجد واذا وجد لم يتم تفعيله
هل اسرائيل ستضرب مفعلات مين يدافع عن مين
هم يعني
لا يعني انت
هل اسرائيل ستضرب مفعلات ايران هي بتهدد
كل يوم على فكره في سؤال جالي
بس انا صديقي اللي طلبت منه انه بس يفكرني
براس الموضوع وبعدين ايه ما بعثتش ثاني او
يمكن بعثه الاسئله كثير احنا عندنا اسئله
كثيره جدا تحت
انا محرج من الناس اللي قلت لهم لو كتبوا
لي راس السؤال هاجاوب بس انا مش فاكر
السؤال ههه سؤال عن ايران انا هاجاوبه انا
انا في سؤال بس انا مش فاكر انا اسف منهم
الاستاذ احمد ابو سمره ومنهم اخ ثاني عشان
انا وعدتهم لكن فيهم سؤال انا فاكره كويس
جدا
ان ايران هي حليفه للولايات المتحده
والاسرائيل وبيدلل على ده بمجموعه من
الاحداث انا اجبت على السؤال اكثر من مره
وسمعت وجهه نظر او قراتها وهو بيستدل في
ذلك على انه همم فضيحه ايران كونترا في
الثمانينات لما الولايات المتحده ادت سلاح
لايران تستخدمه ضد العراق وبيستخدم
وبيستدل على انه لما الولايات المتحده غزه
العراق سلمت العراق على طبق من فضه
وبيستدل كمان على شاهد او اثنين على ما
اذكر يعني
يا صديقي
كل الاحترام لوجهه نظرك القصه هنا
في ناس مقتنعين بالكلام ده انا مش مقتنع
به وجزء من اللي بيروجه لهذه القصه طبعا
ناس مقتنعين كل الاحترام وناس مجرد هو عنه
هو طرف خصومه مع ايران يعني لما تيجي مثلا
السعوديه
ايران تهديد عليها خلاص
لكن عادات لما بتكون في طرف خصومه فانت
بتستخدم كل ادواتك ومنها فكره انك تدغها
بكل ما هو سلبي ما هو سلبي انك تطلعها ان
هي دوله على علاقه بامريكا ودوله على
علاقه باسرائيل فتبدوا ان هي دوله منافقه
ان هي ب- اا بتجاهر همم بعدائهم ليها ولكن
هي صديقه الكلام ده يعني هذا غير سليم
يعني ازاي تبقى انت صديق لدوله بتفرض
عليها عقوبات من سنه 79 هل فرض العقوبات
ده مساله سر يعني عزل ايران او محاوله عزل
ايران عن العالم يعني انت لو سافرت ايران
لو صديق سافر ايران هم هناك في سويسرا بس
مخبيين على الناس في معاناه شديده جدا جدا
جدا
الامر الثاني انه كل وقع من دول ايران
المتحده مسلمتش الاعراق على طبق من فضل
الولايات المتحده ارتكبت مجموعه من
الاخطاء ادت في النهايه الى انه ايران
اللي هي ايجار كبير للعراق المساله تصب في
صالحه ده ما كانش من اولويات الولايات
المتحده هي فشلت في ادارتها للعراق
وادى من بين اوجه فشلها ان ده صب في صالح
الولاد يصب في صالح همم
الايراني يعني لما عملتهوش الولايات
المتحده ما ساعدش اليه
حكايه ايران كونترا قصه شهيره بالمناسبه
ما دام انتم المصريين على ارقامهم بعض
الناس مصريين انا عاوز اعرض لكم اللي قاله
الرئيس رنال دريم اللي كان بطل القصه لانه
كان رئيس الولايات المتحده القصه كانت
مرتبطه بالرهائن الامريكان اللي موجودين
في لبنان واللي كان بيحاول انه يغازل
ايران على امل الافراج عليهم كان في رهائن
امريكان في لبنان وبيعتقد انه ايران
تستطيع انها تلعب دور الوسيط والافراج
عنهم
بالاضافه انه فكره ان دوله اثناء الحرب
حرب قعدت ثمان سنين الحرب العراقيه
الايرانيه قعدت ثمان سنين ان تكون فيه
واقعه واحده
اللي حصل فيها التحقيقات في الكونجرس وعلى
وكتب عنها كل الناس
تحقيقات خارج الكونجرس معناها ان هي حاجه
استثنائيه ما كانتش القاعده القاعده كان
طبعا الولايات المتحده للدقه الغربيه كانت
بتقول انا وحيده انما كل الشواهد بعد مرور
سيرين طويله كانت الطرف اللي بيحصل على
اكبر عدد من الاسلحه وكان العراق وليس
ايران على العموم
يعني مساله ايران بغداد عند الناس يعني ان
انت تحاول ان انت يبقى لك موقف من قضيه
ولك هواء فخلاص انت حر يعني انت لو لان
انا احد بعث لي ثاني اصل انا كان كاتب على
الكمبيوتر ان انا بالمع ايران وبلمع بشار
الاسد ولمع روسيا
يعني على العموم انت بقى بس هو انا عاذره
لان هو كان كاتب بيقول انه ايران وروسيا
وبشر الاسد قتله وبني جلدته واهلي طب انا
طبعا انت انت في طرف خصومه وانا مقدر ده
وانا ما قدرتش اعلق لان انا مش عارف رد
فعل الناس احيانا مش عارف هو فعلا عنده
قضيه وبيدافع عنها ولا هو احيانا داخل
يوسي يعني لكن لو كانت المساله بيعبر انا
فاهم ده والله بس انا ما اقدرش احط نفسي
مكان كل من هو مقدار والا ايهاب بقى همم
يعني انا باحاول بقدر الامكان احلل الامور
وفقا لما يتوفر اليها من المعلومات الكلام
يعني بشار الاسد بالنسبه له قتل احد من
عيلته همم دمر بيته طب خلاص اوكي انا
متفهم ده بس انت بتسالني انا ما بقولكش
بشار الاسد ملاك من السماء ولا انه بوتين
ده قديس ولا انه ايران بلد خيره هي زيها
زي خيرها انا اللي باقول عليه انه
مش انا لوحدي يعني همم ناقش مشكله ايران
دي من وجهه نظر الدول اللي بتحاربها انت
عندك ثلاث اطراف رئيسيه عندك الولايات
المتحده عندك اسرائيل عندك بعض دول الخليج
الولايات المتحده المفروض نظريه ان ما
عندهاش مشكله مع ايران لان المشكله كانت
مشكله الولايات المتحده مع ايران انه
اسرائيل بالدرجه الاولى والناس اللي
متعاطفين مع اسرائيل
شايفين انه لا يجب ان تكون لايران اي قدره
للدفاع عن نفسها
اتفقوا ووقعوا على اتفاق اعتقد شريحه
كبيره من السياسيين الامريكان انها مقبوله
ومرضيه لانه ما عندهمش حل في التعامل مع
دوله امتلكت المهارات والقدرات والمعرفه
الامتلاك السلاح النووي وتطوير الصواريخ
الا بالاقرار ده ومحاوله تحكيم اسرائيل مش
كل اسرائيل جانب من اليمين المتشدد بقياده
نتنياه بالنسبه لدول الخليج
او بالنسبه لعدد من دول الخليج والسعوديه
هو ده العلاقه العاديه بين الدول اللي
مفيش منها ثقه طبيعي انك تشعر زي كل
دولتين ايجار زي الكره بنتكلم على المغرب
والجزائر اي حاجه هتعملها المغرب هتقلق
الجزائر اي حاجه هتعملها الجزائر هتخلق
المغرب ده الوضع ما بين السعوديه وايران
حل ده مش ان ايران تمحه السعوديه
ولان السعوديه تمحي ايران حل دائما
الدولتين بقت عيش وبيزودوا فرصتهم في
القوه في المواجهه بيتطروا عارفين انه في
نهايه المطاف لن تستطيع ان تدمر الدوله
الاخرى ولا يجب ان تسعى لذلك ولكن يجب ان
تتعايش مع خطر موجود على حدودك
راي الاخ سيد بالوزاره المشكله في العراق
هل من الممكن ان تنتج حلولا من شانها حل
بعض الازمات كسابقتها الاجابه تحتاج الى
بعض الوقت لكن انطباعي انها لن تختلف
كثيرا على الحكومات السابقه التي سبقتها
هل الافلام والمسلسلات اعجابنا السلام
عليكم برايك من سينتصر روسيا او نيته
احنا جبنا على السؤال ده برده ما هو
مستقبل العولمه اجبني عليها السيد اشكرك
بشكل شخص على القناه لموضوعيه لابعد درجه
سؤال ملحمه مدى تاثير التراجمناه لماذا لم
تحضر السعوديه برده اجابته
وليه الاسئله بتتكرر ثاني يا صديقي
[موسيقى]
المغرب بتقول انا الصحراء مغربي هي وعارف
انه الصحراويين بيقولوا هي ليست مغربيه
وعارف انه الجزائر بتقول لابد ان ده ليست
مغربيه ولكنهم يجب ان يقبل المغرب بمبدا
حتى تقرير المصير وعارف ان في عدد كان في
دول مش قليل في الاتحاد الافريقي العالم
بيقر بانه
الصحراء ارض المحتله ولا يقبل باي منتجات
مغربيه ومنتجات في الصحراء ثم في الفتره
الاخيره في السنتين ثلاثه بتعمل 2017 2018
بتؤيد تصورات المغرب انه لا يوجد حل لهذه
القضيه الا بالتصور المغربي اللي هي تكون
جزء من المغرب ولكن ده ده حكم ذاتي دي
الاراء المختلفه
وانا متفهم ان انت كمغربي بتقول هذا
الكلام
وللاخرين حق في ان هم يتكلموا مختلف امام
مصر بتقول مصر بتقول حلايب مصريه لما يجي
واحد سوداني يقول حلايب سودانيه نقول له
انت مجرم يعني بيقول وجهه نظر يعني
بيقول ل بلده شايفاه
مساء الخير هل سيكون هناك حل جذري لا اعلم
لملف عديم الجنسيه لا اعلم يا فهد والله
يعني مش عارف تطورات القضيه هناك انت
بتتكلم على دول الخليج وتحديدا الكويت كيف
تستفيد الدوله المصريه من حقل الغاز لا
حكايه انت تمتلك الشركات 90% يعني ايه
يعني هي تاخذ 90% تاخد 10% الحاجات دي
بتبقى انت بتستعين بشركه يعني مثلا اي
دوله اليونان بتجيب شركه زي توتال ولا اي
شركه كبيره وتقول لها انت هتنفقي الاول في
عمليات الاستكشاف والحفر فهي تدفع في حقل
ممكن ما يكونش فيه اصلا هي اولا اعرفنا
موجوده في عمليه الاستكشاف لا مصر ولا
غيرها انا ما دخلتش في تفاصيل بس انا
فهمته على النحو اللي انا بافهم فيه مش
اللي انا النحو اللي انا فايق يعني لا انا
فهمته كما يجري في كل الحقوق
يعني الامتياز دوله بتجيب شركه الشركه دي
بتبقى شركه عندها ملائه ماليه ضخمه لانها
بتصرف على عمليه استكشاف وحفر وتطوير قبل
ما تستفيد من لهم واحد فطبيعي ان هي بيبقى
عندها جزء عائد كبير جدا ثم اذا وجدت
الاكتشاف هي بتاخذ جزء من العوائد والدوله
بتاخذ جزء من العوائد
بس كده يعني انا مش معناه انه في ثلاث
شركات معناه ان هم هياخذوا شركتين عندهم
90% و10% يعني 100% من نصيب الشركات ديت
مع ثلاث شركات ده لا نفهمه ثلاث شركات دول
لما يطلع للغاز هياخذوا ساي مثلا حصه 45%
ولا قصه 55% والتاخد 45 طبعا على حسب
الاتفاق مش ان هم ياخذوا 90 والمصري تاخذ
10 يعني
انت عندك معلومه مختلفه قل لي
احنا بقى لنا ساعه ونصف انا ازعجت الناس
يا اخويا ماندو
السيد بمناسبه انخفاض قيمه الجنيه لماذا
لا يوجد عمله موحده عالميه يمكن التداول
بها دون الحاجه لرفع او خفض قيمتها كما
كان الحال مع الذهب قديما
ازاي تبقى انت
بالنسبه للذهب كان عمله موجوده
او كانت سلعه
تستخدم كعمله لكن العالم تخلى عنها لاسباب
كانت واضحه انه ما فيش ما فيش كميات ذهب
يمكن ان تكفي النشاط الاقتصادي يعني
النشاط الاقتصادي اللي بيحتاج كميه الذهب
كعمله وقتها اللي كان في عدد ساي مثلا ان
العالم كان مليار نسمه مش هيكفي نشاط
اقتصادي لعدد سكان تضعف ثمان مرات وبقينا
ثمانيه مليار نسبه واسباب اخرى
بالنسبه ان يكون عمله موحده ما هي فكره
العمله ان انت تقدر تستخدمها طالما هي مش
مربوطه بالذهب وطالما ان هي ورق بتطبعه ده
بيخضع ليه اعتبارات تتعلق باقتصادك انت
محتاج بتنتج سلع وخدمات قد ايه فانت بتنتج
وفقا لمعادلات حاجه السوق ده الى عملتك ده
من حيث الطباعه وبالتالي
ومعدل التضخم اللي عندك انت عاوز يعني انت
اكثر من معادله بتقول انت محتاج قد ايه
نقد في هذا البلد تطبع ورق قد ايه اذا
كانت عمله موحده هيبقى عندك سياسه نقديه
موحده للعالم كله اساسا نقديه موحده ديت
يعني عندك بنك مركزي واحد للعالم كله طبعا
انت مش ممكن يعني
سلام يا لا تتوقف الحرب سلام يا سيد انا
محمد من لبنان سؤالي ما مصير بلادنا وما
رايك في السيد
اللبناني تقصد يعني ايه السيد حسن نصر ولا
تقصد مين
مصير بلادنا اللي هي تقصد لبنان لبنان صعب
جدا الصعوبه
[موسيقى]
وربنا يعني يتولى اللبنانيين يعني
السلام عليكم ما مصير اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين اجلناها هل تعتقد ان اسرائيل
تستلم اجابناها يا استاذ سيد كثير مهم ان
كنت متخيل وجود قدر عالي من ديمقراطيه في
الغرب والحريه
ولكن الحرب الروسيه الاقتصاديه صدمتني ردت
فعل الغرب والاعلام
كانه كانهم بنفس ديمقراطيه الدول العربيه
انا عارف ان القصه دي فعلا ولفته بس يعني
انا في النهايه بتجيب معلومات منين وبرده
من الاعلام الغرض يعني في اعلام كبير واخذ
موقف متشدد ضد روسيا واحد وكثير مضلل لان
بياخد معلومات من الحكومه كانها في حاله
حرب وفي الغالب الاعلام بياخذ معلوماته
خاصه لو ما كانش لو كان يعني ما عندوش سبب
بيدعوه همم
العكس ذلك يعني انما هتلاقي في وسائل
الاعلام كثيره واساتذه جامعات وسياسيين
بيطلعوا ويتكلموا بيروحوا بيوتهم امانه
وبيعارضوا البيت الابيض وبيعارضوا
الحكومه
الانجليزيه البريطانيه يعني هو الفرنسيه
وبيقولوا كلام كبير جدا وبيبحثوا ويجيبوا
ملفات فساد ويجيبوا كلام خطير يعني يقود
الروايه الحكوميه في الغرب تجاه الحرب
وبالتالي انا بقول ان الحريه مش ان انت
صحيفه واحده
او وسيله اعلام متبنيه وجهه نظر الحكومه
واتفقت معاها مش هيلحق بها ضرر كثير ان
اختلفت مع الحكومه يعني ده اللي انا بتكلم
عليه ما تنساش ان في مزاج عام في الغرب ما
هو الغرب مش كله مثقف يعني في مزاج عام ان
الصينيين اشرار والروز دول بشعين في برده
في ثقافه زي المفروض سنين طويله لانه اي
مسلم ده ارهابي يعني مش لان الحكومه
الاعلام هناك مش حر ولكن الصوره مش واصله
ان في اعلام يرى فيه طبقه كبيره هناك فعلا
بتعتقد انه بوتن خطر على الغرب يعني
اعتبارات كثيره لكن على العموم يعني قولي
نقول لا يعني انا مازلت اقرا انه في حريه
كبيره للاعلان هناك وتقدر تجيب معلومات
كثيره عن اي قضيه بنسبه كبيره جدا من
التجرد ومن الشفافيه
السلام عليكم هل يوجد السلام عليكم برايكم
من هل ممكن تنفس دوله مثل مصر بدون وجود
مناخ سياسي لا مش ممكن تقصد بدون حريه
سياسيه لا مش ممكن ولا غير مصر لازم الاول
تكون في قدر معقول من الحريات اللي بيسمح
للناس للتعبير عن اراها وده مش معناها ان
الناس تنزل في الشارع وتبقى الصوره فوضويه
بالضروره يعني ولكن معناها انه لو في قضيه
ما من من اتجاه الزراعه اتجاه الصناعه
اتجاه السياسه النقديه ان يكون فيه 100 او
200 او 1000 خبير بيعبروا عن ارائهم
بسهوله ودونا الشعور بان هم لو قالوا رايي
مختلف
عن الدوله او عن الحكومه يتعرضوا للخطر ده
هو اللي يخلي الامور احسن في مصر وفي غير
مصر
ربنا يسعد اوقاتك نحبكم ونحترمك ربنا
يخليك يا عبد اللطيف اشكرك جدا اتمنى لو
حضرتك تغير مكملتش يا احمد اغير الايه
مساء الخير اي حد غير صديقي ممدوده طبعا
مش كده ولا قصدك ايه ههه
مساء الخير هل سيكون هناك حل جذري لملف
ابناء ما هو مصير الاتفاق النووي وهل سوف
يتم ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني على
قائمه الارهاب الحارس السوري الايران
بتعتبر جزء من الجيش اذا
اضربوه هيعقدوا المسائل اكثر ما هي معقده
مصير الاتفاق النووي وهو مجمد امريكا مش
قادره والرئيس الامريكي قال انه مات خلاص
بس يعني الرئيس الامريكي مشغول بمشاكل
كثيره هو خلال الشهور اللي جايه هيبقى
عنده مشكله انه سايب الازمه والازمه
بتتطور وايران بالتطور من قدرتها وعندك
حكومه متطرفه في اسرائيل
الشيء الوحيد اللي بيمنع من ضرب ايران هي
قدراتها الكبيره ان هو اذا ضربوها هيكون
ردها متعب جدا للاسرائيليين وللامريكان
والمصالحهم في المنطقه وبالتالي كله خائف
انه يبدا بندوره بوكس ونفتح هذا الصندوق
المدمر واذا كان حد عنده راي ثاني يقول لي
ايه اللي من من ضربها يعني
اسف افتكرت صديقنا اللي كان بيكلمني عن
ايران
اضاف الى كل اللي انا قلته انه همم
ايران كونترا في الثمانينات والتسليم
العراق وقال انه اسرائيل لو كانت جده هي
ضربت سوريا وضربت العراق من غير ما تتردد
لكن لم تضرب ايران ايوه صحيح ضربت سوريا
والعراق لان كانت امكانياتهم ابسط بكثير
العواقب ابسط بكثير وكان في عنصر المفاجاه
لسوريا وعنصر المفاجاه للعراق اللي كانت
مشتركه في حرب العراق وايران يعني هي
اسرائيل ضربت العراق امتى لما كان الاول
مشتبك في حرب طويله مش هيقدر يفتح جبهتين
وقدراته وقتها حتى لو كان مش مشترك اقل من
ايران والسوريا كانت وما زالت قدرتها اقل
من اسرائيل فوجئت ثم ان البرنامج كان سر
في الحالتين ولا تريد المجاهره به يعني
لما انضرب في حاله سوريا اتضرب مبنى سوريا
انقرض اصلا العمليه يعني لما تفزع عن
العمليه لانه هي ما كانش بتقول انا باطور
سلاح ناو
انما ايران بتقول انا بطور برنامج ناوي
السلمي والبرنامج متطور واصبح قادره على
يعني تخصيب اليورانيوم وعندها الصواريخ
العابره للقارات وعندها كل حاجه
النهارده وعندها الحجر
وبيتم تهديدها كل يوم فهي مستعده تماما
وعندها القدره ان هي من جبهه لبنان فقط
حزب الله ان تمطر اسرائيل
على الاقل باكثر من 100,000 صاروخ
وبالتالي الوضع مختلف هي مش قادره تضرب
ايران مش لانها بتحب ايران لان انا خايفه
تضرب ايران بس انا كل القصه
[موسيقى]
ما اعرفش انا مش عارفه اقرا اول كلمه من
عليكم انها صحراويه لو كانت كذلك
اخرجت كل اهل الجنوب هناك في الصحراء
الغربيه وقاموا
انا اسف مش فاهم الصيغه يمكن انا ارهاقت
بس مش عارف يعني
واضح ان هو معترض على حاجه يعني هل ترى
اذا كنت بتتكلم على قريه الصحراء انا مليش
رايك في قناه الصحراء يا صديقي الناس اللي
بيطلبوا اي حد انا وغيري انا علشان اقول
راي اولا القضيه مش انت بتقول لي مثلا في
قضايا ممكن تاخذ راي حد فيها وتقول له
مثلا مثلا هل الافضل للمغرب ان هي تطور
علاقتها مع السيد مثلا اسبانيا او هل
الافضل ان هي همم تستخدم التهديدات مع
اسبانيا هل تطور سلاح نووي هل تقيم علاقات
مع اسرائيل فالناس ممكن تقول رايي لكن لما
تيجي تقول
هل اي منطقه من العالم تابعه لايه ده انت
لازم يكون عندك وثائق ودرس تاريخ كله
وجايب الوثائق كلها وعارف الكلام على
الارض وبتقول انه الجزء ده هو تابع للمغرب
هو مش تبع للمغرب وطبيعي ان هي محل خلاف
كل واحد عنده وثائقه انا انا كسيد انا ليس
له رايي في المساله
ومش من المنطقه انه كل واحد بيتصدى
للعلاقات الدوليه ويكون عنده راي في كل
قضيه تتعلق بالحدود يعني انا ما اعتقدش ان
في احد حتى يعني همم
يعني اذا كان اذا كان مش من ابناء البلد
اللي هو بدافع الوطنيه انه يتبنى وجهه نظر
معينه ان كل راي في القضايا دي انا كل ما
علي ان انا اعرض وجهات النظر وازاي القضيه
ديت بتعقد وبتشكل العلاقات المغرب
والجزائر لا اكثر ولا اقل
انا لم اقل ان الصحراء ليست مغربيه ولا
العكس انا بقول المغرب بقول الصحراء
مغربيه وبالنسبه له قضيه مصيريه وحقق في
الفتره الاخيره مجموعه من الانتصارات
الدبلوماسيه لان اقنع مجموعه من الدول
بتاييد وجهه نظر
الصحراويين الجزائر
تراجع
ادائهم في دعم هذه
القضيه مؤخرا لانه الجزائر كان مشغول
بمشاكله الداخليه و بمرض والشلل السياسي
اللي كان موجود ياما الرئيس بوتفليقه رحمه
الله
واضطرابات الداخليه ودلوقتي بيحاول انه
يعني ياخذ نقاط او سكورس على المغرب في
هذه القضيه الجزائر لها وجهه نظر انا
عرضتها بالكامل وبالاضافه الى وجهه النظر
وفكره انه ده تفكيك للاحتلال لانها
بتعتبرها اخر منطقه احتلال في افريقيا
وبالاضافه الى مواقفها السياسه العامه
يعني في الدفاع عن حق تقرير المصير هي
كمان عندها مصالح هي عندها تتمنى ان يكون
لها اطلاله على المحيط الاطلنتي من همم
دوله تكون صديقه هي بغض النظر الجزائريين
بيغضبوا من المساله ديت الجزائر
طاقتهم بالمغرب حتى لو بعيدا عن اطلال عن
المغرب والمصالح والفوسفات وكل الكلام ده
هي في حاجه بسيطه جدا بتحكم سلوك الجزائر
وهي همم بلنس اوف باور انه انا في حاله
صراع وخصومه مع المغرب فكل ما يقوي المغرب
ضعفني وكل ما يضعف المغربي يقويني
همم فرجاء متاخدوش المساله بحساسيه لمني
ولا من غيري زي ما لم يكن انت شايفني انا
باروغ لوجهه نظر ثانيه انا ما باروقش
لوجهه نظر ثانيه وباقول لحضرتك انا بحلل
بس القصه لا اكثر ولا اقل يعني
هل ترى اصلاحات هيكليه بالاقتصاد المصري
لا ارى اصلاحات هيكليه في الوقت الحالي
بشكل يعني كبير بتجري من فتره ولكن
الاصلاح الاكبر
بينصرف او بينصب على
التعديلات النقديه والماليه لكن اصلاح
اقتصادي بمعنى اصلاح مناخ الاستثمار بشكل
جذري همم قوانين العمل قوانين الضرائب
قوانين ال- همم
تنفيذ الاحكام الامور ديت لا مش مش بنفس
الوتيره يعني وتيره بطيئه ودائما كانت
بوتيره بطيئه
اليس رجاء رجاءا نريد حلقه عن عن عمله
البريكس هما ما عملوش عمله للبريكس التي
اعلن عنها
لم يكن في حاجه انا ما سمعتهاش كانوا
بيتكلموا على التوسع في استخدام عمولات
دول البريكس الخمسه فيما بينهم فلوروسيا
عاوزه تدي قرض مثلا همم لجنوب افريقيا ولو
ان العلاقه مش عظيمه ما بينهم يعني دلوقت
او ان البرازيل عاوزه مثلا تتعامل مع
الصين فيتامله فيما بينهم بعملات الدول
الخمس
اما عموله مشتركه انا مسمعتش يجوز قال
وانا ما سمعتش بس ما سمعتش الحقيقه روسيا
تبيع الغرب طبعا تبيع روسيا تبع الغرب
يعني تبع ولا تبيع هي اكيد مش تبع الغرب
مساء الخير هل سيكون هناك معرفش برده ملف
عليه بالجنسيه هل سيتاح
هل سيجتاح بوتن مولدوفا بحجه وجود اقليات
روسيه بتقلد اسوا وقت انه بوتن ممكن يعمل
عمليه عسكريه في دوله اخرى
بمناسبه انخفاض لماذا لا يجرى اعجبناها ما
هي ما هي التحديات الضمان في اللاندا
والسويد للنيتو وما هو موقف باطن الحالي
والله بودن الحلال انا ما عنديش مشكله بعد
ما قال انا عندي مشكله طبعا ببساطه لانه
متورط في حرب اوكرانيا
انما قال انا هارد بشكل مبتكر طبعا قاله
ان احنا ما عندناش مشكله ان هم ينضم وهم
عندهم مشكله انه في لندن بس قالوا كده
لانه اذا قال عندي مشكله يبقى اهم مطالب
من الرؤوس انه يتصرف وهو صعب جدا يتصرف
دلوقت
لكن قال ينضم لكن اذا هم حطوا سلاح الحلفه
شمال الاطلسي على حدودي فانا وقتها اتصرف
وكان التصرف المعلن ان هم يحطوا قواعد
عسكريه على حدود في اللاندا والسويد الامر
اللي بيهدد السعيد وفي اللاندا
قناه الجزيره ما اعرفش يعني معناها ايه ده
استاذ سيد اشكرك بشكل شخص على القناه
الموضوعيه لابعد درجه سؤال ملحمه مدى
تاثير اجابنا هل يوجد بنك اجابنا
ده احمد زين بيقول لي لو تغير النظاره
لانها مش جميله حاضر حاضر غير النظاره
السلام عليكم استاذ سيد تحياتي لحضرتك من
انجلترا اجابنا
هي موضوع عمله البركه واضح ان هو حاجه انا
مش عارفها يعني انا ما سمعتش عنهم يطلقوا
عمله بريكس كان مبادره انا لم اسمع عنها
اسمحوا لي اراجع معلوماتي وارجع لكم
هل تعتقد لو سمحت احنا قدامنا كده كمان
دقيقتين تمام
احنا عندنا اسئله كثير قوي
كثير قوي
هل تعتقد ان اسرائيل هل همم
هيبتدي يطلع اسئله اصحاب دلوقتي
هل تعتقد ان اسرائيل لا لو سمحت استاذ سيد
وليد الحلق عن الفروق بين البنوك العاديه
والاسلاميه والله ما في فروق ما تزعلش مني
يعني
انا انا مش عاوز اقول حاجه ممكن تبقى فجاه
يعني بس ده موضوع كبير بس
الاجابه المختصره انا مش شايف ان في فروق
عاوزين اجابه اوسع بقى ممكن نخصص لها حلقه
هل تتوقع في نسبه ترتاح يعني هو عاوز يسمى
عائد ومش عاوز يسميها فائده خلاص يعني كل
الاحترام بس في الاخر ادي لك اجابه مختصره
اختار 10 بنوك اسلاميه في بلدك اذا كان
عندك العدد ده وقارن العائد اللي هيديه لك
بمستوى الفايده اللي بتديه لك البنوك
التقليديه وقل لي الفرق قد ايه يعني
احسبها انت بالقلم والورقه اذا وجدت فروق
متغيره وكبيره استاذنك تواصل معك في
الغالب هتلاقي
يعني على مدار السنه هو تقريبا واحد
هل تتوقع ان هناك اتفاق نووي مع ايران هذه
السنه انا اللي قلقان منه ما يكونش في
اتفاق يعني مش عارف الازمه هتروح لفين
يعني هو اكيد السنه دي هم اللي اتفق ميت
فانا مش عارف وبوتنهام
واسرائيل بقت اسوا بتولي نتنياهو السلطه
ما تغيرتش في ايران وفي قاعده بيقول لك ان
اي ازمه
لابد من ان تجد لها حالا اذا لم تجد لها
حلا يعني تجاهلتها
اجلتها فالازمه بتتحل بنت القائمه نفسها
ولكن ليس في الاتجاه الذي تريد انت عندك
ازمه سيبه سيبه انت عندك مثلا البنيه
التحتيه للبيت والاساسيات بتتهالك سبتها
هتلاقي انه الميه بتتسرب من السباكه
بتلاقي ان سقف بيسقط بتلاقي بتحصل ماساه
فكذلك تجاهل الازمه في ايران معناها ان
ايران هتتحايل على العقوبات ايران تطور
سلاح ناوي بها القدرات نوويه همم
[موسيقى]
حاجه مش هتبقى لصالح ممكن تبقى طبعا
الايرانيين هيعانوا بالعقوبه اكثر انما ده
مش كل صالح الولايات المتحده يعني ما
يهمناش مصالح الاولاد المتحده على كل حال
انها الخلافه العثمانيه وليست امبراطوريه
كل الاحترام دي وجهه نظرك
ماذا تستفيد امريكا اجابنا السلام عليكم
اجابنا الصحراء المغربيه يا ناس
البوليساريو جمهوريه الوهم انشائها انشاء
الاحتلال الاسباني برده كل الاحترام وجهه
نظرك لماذا الاجتماع ابو ظبي ده انا كتبته
من ضمن ثلاث ملاحظات حاضر اعتقد استاذنكم
اختم بسؤالين كمان السلام عليكم ارجو ان
تلخص لنا ما يحدث في تونس وكيف ترى خلاص
من الغم الذي اصابع واقع تونسيين
استاذ عبير تونس دوله
بتتعرض لاي دوله بتتعرض لما تتعرض له اول
دوله بعد عمليه اضطرابات عنيفه جدا يعني
تونس في 2010 و2011 تغير نظامها السياسي
وعلى مدار اكثر من 12 سنه حكومات متعاقبه
مشغوله
بمحاوله التعامل مع الزلزال الكبير بتغير
الساحه السياسيه اللي حصل انه مع الفراغ
السياسي اللي موجود كل القوى انشغل القوى
التونسيه وبصراحه ده اللي بيحصل في كل
مكان ما تقدرش تلونيهم يعني ان كل دوله
عاوزه تسيطر على السياسه
وتسيطر على البلد وبقى في صراع سياسي مع
الصراع السياسي الطويل اللي حصل على مدار
12 سنه وهملت كل المؤسسات الاقتصاديه
وطبيعي ان لو كانت دوله كانت هتعاني فما
بالك بدوله اقتصادها صغير السياحه محدوده
الانتاج محدود قدرتها على التعامل مع
الازمات اللي بتنتج عن الكوارث الطبيعيه
او التغير المناخي محدوده اا كمان العالم
من 2010
مشغول بمشاكله الكثيره
2010 دول كثيره كانت لسه ما افاقتش من
ازمه 2008
وجت كورونا وقال حرب روسيه الاوكرانيه
فاللي بيحصل في تونس ماساوي ولكنه نتيجه
متوقعه ممكن ظروف تونس تونس احسن مناخيرها
في المناسبه يعني هي مرشحه ان هي تكون
في وضع افضل مقارنه بدول مش قادره تخرج
خالص من ازماتها انما في كل الاحوال مشكله
تونس ان هي
النخب السياسيه مشغولين به مستقبل
والاوضاع السياسيه ومش قادرين اللي عندهم
الوقت ولا القدر انه يهتموا به همم يعني
مصادر الرزق تونسيين
السلام عليكم كيف ترى ايه هو احسن سناريو
ممكن الفلسطينيين وقضيتهم هل حل الدولتين
ممكن مستقبلا ولا اصبح مستحيل
هي اسرائيل عاوزه لحل الدوله تاني
احسن وضع في فلسطين طبعا انه تنفس قرارات
الامم المتحده يبقى عندها دوله بس ده مش
هتوافق مش ممكن توافق عليه اسرائيل مختاره
لازم تكبر عليه وموازين القوه لا تسمح
بذلك
يعني في تقارب
انا استاذنكم ان تقريبا احنا بقينا الساعه
:00 انا عارف انه ما زالت فيه اسئله كثيره
جدا بس احنا بقى لنا ساعتين
انا استاذنكم انه نتوقف عند هذا القدر وان
شاء الله
نكمل في الحلقه المقبله
وبعتذر على عدد الاسئله لملحقتهاش لكن ان
شاء الله
الحلقه المقبله مبدئيا بعد اسبوعين ان شاء
الله اجاوب على اكبر قدر من اسئله حضراتكم
انا شاكر جدا جدا جدا لصبركم وباعتذر جدا
عن الاسئله التي لم يتم الاجابه عليها
وان شاء الله نتمكن من الاجابه عليها
المره الجايه ممكن الناقل بعض الاصدقاء
اللي انا جاءت اسئلتهم المره دي ما لحقتش
لو هو بعثها لي لاحقا على صفحه فيسبوك او
على كومنتي اسجل بها وابدا بها مباشر
المره الجايه ان شاء الله ربنا يسعد
ليلتكم شكرا جزيلا والقاكم على خير